all right uh good afternoon everyone uh
welcome to the bokeh tutorial here at
petta San Francisco 2016 hope everyone's
had um a really uh useful um good
exciting day here at the first day of Pi
data the tutorials um just coming down
the home stretch I think we got the last
tutorial um sort of Series going on
right now so today um I'm here to talk
about bokeh which is a library for data
visualization uh from python from other
languages uh in modern browsers um and
so we'll be going over sort of some
Basics but really today the focus is
going to be covering some of the more
sophisticated data application um
interaction kind of capabilities that
bokeh affords so uh anyway my name is
Brian vandan I work for Continuum
analytics U very happy to be here I
normally in Austin Texas but very happy
to come out to high data to be here
today um you can reach me at Big Red Dot
if you care to tweet at me anyway so uh
just a quick overview of what we'll go
over today I only have a couple of
slides um typically I have a very
Hands-On kind of tutorials hope
everyone's ready to do a little bit of
coding or uh pair coding with your
neighbor um well it's a complete wrong
order let's just bring them all up sorry
about that last minute slides so the
first thing is just sort of an overview
of what bokeh is and and uh you know
also what we'll be covering um the
tutorial has actually grown quite a bit
in size in the last six months or so um
it's a series of Jupiter notebooks uh we
don't have nearly enough time to go over
all of it so we're just going to pick
and choose today and uh and we'll see
what we have time for but um anyway I'll
go over that and just just a second uh I
also wanted to do just a couple of demos
both of you know things we'll be talking
about but also some of the upcoming
features so you know bokeh has been
under heavy development for a couple of
years now and we're really sort of
rounding things out and heading towards
sort of a 1.0 release hopefully in the
next few months so at least want to give
maybe a preview of some some fun things
that are coming up uh then we'll spend a
little bit of time just for installation
and setup make sure everyone's ready to
go has everything installed that they
need to have installed in order to work
the exercises and then in terms of the
chapters for the the tutorial I am going
to start sort of Fairly basic with the
the sort of Boke out plotting API uh
sort of go over that section A little
bit but then we're going to move into
some more sophisticated things involving
layouts and widgets and interactions
that you can add in Standalone documents
and then we'll move on to what you can
do with the bokeh server uh in terms of
of Hosting really sophisticated
applications U using bokeh and then
finally hopefully we'll have some time
at the end for questions as well so uh
first thing um actually we'll have some
more detailed installation instructions
I guess in a notebook in a minute but
you can use condo or pip to install fok
however you like um probably also want
to install the jupyter notebook so uh
cond install notebook or I think uh you
know pip install IPython brackets
notebook will also work um but the main
thing is all of the tutorial materials
are in jupyter notebooks and so you can
go to that URL at the bottom it'll take
you to NB viewer uh site that Jupiter
hosts where there's a bunch of hosted
notebooks uh and you there you'll find
the bokeh tutorial notebooks and so let
me just show you what that looks
like
so if we click on this link here or if
you go to it uh go to page right so this
is actually at nbv viewer. jupiter. org
but this is what you should see is this
notebook and so from here we're going to
be going over several of these notebooks
I bring this URL down at the
bottom uh but not all of them because we
won't have
time so there's that URL at the bottom
there's what you should see I'll give
everyone just a couple of minutes to get
navigated there if anyone has any
problems please raise your hands let me
know definitely if anyone has any
questions uh at any time during the
tutorial please raise your hand or
holler at me grab my attention and I'll
come take a look um and also as you work
the exercises if you have any questions
I'm happy to come uh Wander out and uh
and help people with questions that you
might have so uh said it's a very
Hands-On tutorial um I think this
section is a little bit this last slot
of the day is a little bit longer so
we'll probably take a little break in
the middle as well so I think at least
on the schedule it has us going to 5:15
so we'll probably take maybe a 10-minute
Break um about an hour in okay so like I
said we'll we'll get everyone just a
minute to get there um as everyone's
finding this page um you'll note there
is a download button up here at the top
so you can click this download button to
actually download The Notebook locally
so all of the notebooks have been
statically rendered in this NB viewer
site but if you actually want to run the
code you'll want to download it locally
and you'll want to run IPython notebook
on that notebook file and then you can
actually execute the python code and and
do the exercises um here on this NB side
it's just a static rendering of the
notebooks
yeah that I believe is a q yeah let's
see if I can make that a little bit
bigger yeah let's see if we can make
that a bit
bigger
uh maybe
not well it
doesn't
funny not giving me text options okay
well there's format okay make that
bigger
yeah just keep making that as big as
possible all right is anyone having any
trouble finding or getting to this NB
viewer site to find the notebooks
everyone got it okay so then in that
case uh I'm going to go to a locally
running version of The Notebook that
I've got up and running and just talk
about sort of you know this intro slide
this section 00 intro uh as well as talk
about what we're going to be covering
and sort of we're not going to be
covering in in this tutorial today so
again just for time reasons U we're not
going to be able to go over you know not
even really half of the sections there
but just so you know what's there um
bokeh itself is split up into a number
of high level AP or different apis
there's a high level charts API we're
not going to cover that today there's
the basic plotting interface which we
are going to cover today um there's lots
of ways to style lots of knobs and dials
that you can turn to style and configure
pretty much any aspect of a Bou plot I
don't think we'll get to that today
unless we have time um sharing and
embedding is another useful section but
uh we're not going to get to that we're
going to skip all the way down to voke
Applications I think that's one of the
newer uh capabilities that people are
really curious about so again we're
going to be doing the basic plotting
interface the layouts widgets and
interactions uh and then the bokeh
application sections but just so you
know again there's also sections now on
some Geographic type things and there's
actually a lot of current interest in
developing that capability even more in
the near future uh data Shader which is
a related Library under the bokeh
organization for dealing with very large
data sets hundreds of millions or
billions of points and I might do a
quick demo of some of that and then
Hollow views is another sort of open
source project that uh one of our other
contributors at Continuum and his team
have worked on it's really great in The
Notebook for basically automatically
slicing and dicing data and creating
nice little goys uh based on uh you know
the the shape and and the way your data
is actually laid out so any that's sort
of an idea of what all you can get there
we we'll cover what we can cover today
okay so as I mentioned what is Bok let
me make this font bigger uh library for
interactive visualization it's targeting
modern browsers it really wants to be
able to provide very uh versatile
Graphics that you can create we want
able to create Standalone HTML documents
that you know you could just send to
somebody and not have any kind of server
but also to be able to have very rich
and sophisticated uh serverb documents
as well we want able to handle streaming
data uh large data sets uh and of course
you know at Continuum we're a big python
shop so we've invested heavily in Python
bindings but actually there are other
bindings for bokeh as well there's b.
Scala B.R uh and so if you're interested
in using bokeh from those languages
those are available those are actually
created by outside contributors so um
there's a lot of interest and a lot of
new outside contributors coming in to
help with the project and it's really
exciting so what can we do with B well
um first thing we can do here we are in
the Jupiter notebook so who all is
familiar with the Jupiter
notebook just about everybody who
actually who else familiar with
BKE okay about half okay so that's good
so we're gonna so we're going to have a
brief sort of intro starting kind of
from the beginning and then we're going
to dive into some more sophisticated
stuff but hopefully it'll be a nice uh
collection of things for everybody so
here in the notebook we have some some
sort of standard inputs right so here I
want to import uh output notebook
because we're we're working in the
Jupiter notebook I want to import this
show function and then I want to call
output notebook and we can see that
bokeh is ready to go in the notebook
because we have this nice message that
said it's successfully loaded uh there a
little logo there and then we can do
things like uh create a histogram right
so here I'm using my high level bokeh
charts interface to create a very simple
histogram and so you notice that it's
actually wanted to group this data by
species so we can say color equals
species there's a column species in our
data and that automatically will
generate that and so this API I think is
very nice for sort of very quick you
know oneliner sort of exploratory data
analysis type
things but you can also create um much
more Rich type applications so here's a
reproduction of Hans rising's uh you
know Gap minder demo uh and so you can
see this has this nice slider at the
bottom and we can scrub the slider and
sort of see the data update this doesn't
require any kind of server this is this
just HTML and JavaScript right um and if
you actually go into uh the bokeh
notebooks you can see this get Gap
minder plot um there's also a server
version of this that I'll show in a
little bit as well but this is
definitely the kind of thing you can do
uh fairly straightforward with bok as
well um the last thing of course is we
can do uh these server applications so
here I'm just going to go ahead and
iframe one in from the demo. Boke plots.
com site that you can also go check out
um this is a very simple app that has a
bunch of Sliders and I can you know I
can scrub the offset here the amplitude
or change the phase the frequency I can
say my you know Pi
Data San Francisco sinewave and have
that update so this is actually going
back you know to the bokeh server that's
running on demo. boots.com that's
serving this uh application to us uh and
then you know causing the update so if
you have some code that wants to do uh
you know respond to user selections or
to widgets the voke server is a great
way to create applications that do that
and so we'll see a lot of examples of
that
today
okay so quick quick note without going
to too much detail about how all this
Works um so the main thing is that you
know instead of actually creating like
JavaScript code to send to the browser
Boke is actually composed uh of two
libraries there's sort of a python half
of it and then there's a separate
Library called bokehjs and the interface
between them is this declarative Json
spec um and so any language that can
generate the right Json can drive bokeh
plots in the browser again we're big
python shop a Continuum so we've really
heavily invested in sort of very
sophisticated python bindings for bokeh
but um you know you can generate you
know anyone any language you want could
generate bokeh plots if it generates the
right Json and so again that's why we
have bokeh you know R Boke and b. Scala
um and actually there was a b. Lua and
briefly and also a b. Julia so if
there's anyone here interested in Julia
we're actually I'd love to try to help
find a new maintainer for book at Julia
because it hasn't been updated in a
while
but okay so getting set up so what do we
need to get set up so uh again the
things you're going to want for this
tutorial are um Jupiter
Jupiter notebook uh bokeh the newest
version is actually 0 12.1 probably what
you'll get today if you condo or pip
install it um and you also want to get
um actually that's it just bokeh and the
jupyter notebook should be pretty good
um pandis isn't really required uh the
high Lev book at at charts API does
require pandas but um the core Library
doesn't uh and that should be pretty
good so let me give everyone um just a
few minutes to get set up if you have
any problems installing things or uh you
know getting things ready to go let me
know but once you have everything there
you should be able to do something like
this uh you know import the version um
you know print the I python version the
pandas version uh and you should see
something like that so give everyone
just a couple of minutes to get set up
again raise your hand holler at me if
you have any uh problems I guess in the
meantime while people are getting set up
if there are any questions right now
before we really dive into things take
those as
well everyone got their post lunch food
coma going on
sure
okay well um as long as people are still
getting uh setting up I'm going to go
ahead and run through again just a
couple of quick demos so I want to give
maybe a preview of some things then in
the tutorial but also in future
coming up versions of BKE so one thing
that's sort of been missing for a long
time because we really wanted to wait
for some improved layout capabilities is
is actually a very simple thing um but
if you follow bokeh for a while you'll
be happy to see that there's at least a
path forward for adding lat Tech
annotations right so this is actually
using a custom extension this is not
sort of built into the library there's
an example that shows how you can write
an extension to do this we'll figure out
how to add it to the library uh you know
proper the core library but for the the
time being there's a nice really nice
example that you can use you can uh take
this sort of custom latch label
extension and and uh and use it in your
own code if you need to add things like
latch labels to uh to your own plots I
should mention I'm really excited about
the sort of extensibility capability
that we've added to bokeh recently um
you know there a small team working on
sort of a large project with a really
quickly growing user base it's kind of
hard to keep up with both feature
requests um you know all kinds of things
that people want some things may never
make sense to go in the core library but
it still be great if there's a path
people to use them and so this
extensibility is is really fantastic it
lets people sort of not have to wait on
us right sort of serve and create all
kinds of interesting new capabilities
that Bok can do you know if there's some
amazing new JavaScript library dour that
you want to wrap and and use and connect
it to python data analytics in on the
back end uh bokeh makes it really easy
to do that and so I'm excited about that
uh and I'm hoping to have a nice
mechanism for people to share these
contributions if you think of like the
atom you know sort of uh plugin loader I
want to have something similar to that
for bokeh so people can create uh these
contributions and these extensions and
share them very easily and I think
that'll magnify the value uh across the
entire community so that's sort of
things that are coming up as well that's
one thing another thing that's been
missing for a while that people have
asked for um probably shouldn't be so
bragging about it that took so long to
get us we'll have some color bars very
soon in the next 022 release so again
this is really waiting on some layout
capabilities that only just now sort of
came crystallized we didn't want to sort
of write something hacky and and then
have to redo some work we just don't
have the ability to sort of throw work
away but um anyway so that's that's
coming very soon in the next actually
should be a couple of weeks in the next
release uh since we are talking about uh
bokeh applications today I actually want
to show you what some of these are um so
if you go to demo. pls.com you can check
these out yourself but um you know here
we can click on this one here and we can
see this nice sliders app and so you
know I can go and I can I can change it
and the thing about this is that it's a
very tiny amount of code right if you
actually look at the code for that
entire app you know have a scalable uh
Deployable web web application there's
no web code in here there's just some
python some imports uh we'll talk about
what all this is later uh some code to
add the the widgets a call back and
pretty much done right so very tiny
amount of code to have these kind of
applications um another one shows off a
nice capability is you know what if you
want to respond to things like user
selections right so this actually shows
some histograms of the data and then if
you make a selection you get a a
histogram both of the selected points
and then in the mirror image the
unselected points as well and so this is
the kind of thing you can do with uh you
know Bou server uh plots is respond to
things like
selections um another one here again
this is sort of a server version of that
Gap minder example we can hit a little
play button here and sort of a little
animate through and and go and update
everything this also shows off the
capability for using Ginga templates
right so voke applications now can have
their own uh templates so uh if you if
you're in the realm of sort of a single
page application that you want to have
heavily centered around sort of uh you
know bokeh plots or visualizations or
things like that it's really easy to
make just a straight Bok server
application not have to embed it you
know in something
else okay um last few here again another
example of a custom extension model
there's nothing built into bokeh for 3D
stuff but I found this nice little
Library called VJs and I wrote you know
10 lines of extension code to sort of uh
adapt the viz JS data structure to a
bokeh column data source uh and then use
the streaming API to push data to it and
so we can have this nice sort of 3D
thing so again the whole idea behind the
extension API is that people don't have
to wait on us if there's something
really cool or amazing you want to do uh
we don't have to be the the gating
Factor you know people can do uh really
awesome things uh on their own so I'm
very excited about that um what are some
other good ones here last one um again
using templates is this nice little sort
of cross filter application that um one
of our developers Brendan Collins put a
lot of work into um you know this if you
maybe want to color it by the horsepower
horse uh horsepower column or you know
change the size according to the miles
per gallon uh you're able to sort of do
that um this is using the auto MPG or I
think it's also called Mt cars data set
okay um last but not least we also
wanted to do sort of a comparative one
this is actually a reproduction of the r
shiny uh movie app uh with a couple of
small changes um but you know here you
can see we can you know again scrub
sliders and sort of these things update
um sort of as fast as we'd want so
anyway this is um sort of what we're
getting to so we'll talk a lot about the
details of of what goes into a bouet app
a little bit later on in the tutorial
today but I wanted to give you an idea
of what's there for another example of a
really cool one um if you actually go
watch the recent Sci-Fi talk that Matt
Rocklin and Jim Chris gave uh about dask
which is this distributed array
scheduler they were a really fantastic
um bokeh app that uh you know so dask is
this schedule it lets you schedule jobs
across you know whatever 32 64 cores uh
and they want to be able to monitor the
performance of this and see what's going
on in real time and so they wrote this
Boke app you can sort of see over here
on the right that will start showing
exactly what's going on as the
computations proceed you know uh you can
sort of see all kinds of like here these
cores are doing know compute jobs or I
think yellow means IO or something else
means blocking and so they can see in
real time what all the different cores
in this cluster are doing what you know
what the D jobs or what state they're in
and so this I think is a really
fantastic job and so they used a lot of
nice techniques to sort of build this uh
this uh cluster management tool using a
bokeh application so again you can see
that if you go to the the scipi talks on
YouTube you can see uh you can see the
dask talk there
okay last but not least uh I always have
to show this when I've been trying to
show it in its full glory for a few
years um originally wrote this
spectrogram app several years ago and
originally it was actually a lot of
javascripts using bokehjs directly maybe
600 lines or something like that uh
which was sort of cool to look at but
nothing you'd ever want to write um and
then we got a little bit better using uh
more Python and less JavaScript now we
have a bokeh server version that's
really um hardly any JavaScript at all
so this is really just using bokeh Code
you know and you can do things like
scrub the slider and and see the things
change and so this is actually doing a a
for you transform it's reading the
microphone off there and doing the
spectral analysis and you can see the
the power spectrum and the signal and
it's you know it just shows up and so
this is again the kind of thing we
wanted to enable been trying to to write
this app for a couple of years and we're
finally in a position now where we can
actually write uh write this almost
completely um as a bokeh server app with
one small custom extension model um to
help with the streaming of the uh the
image
data okay got
that and then last but not least I just
want to mention again we're not going to
talk about it too much today as I just
wanted to mention this Associated data
Shader project it's really for uh
dealing with much larger data sets so um
there's just a simple demo here in the
tutorial but you can take a look at it
you know on your own uh but what data
Shader is meant to do is to do uh
offline or not in the browser
rasterization right so if you have 10
million or 100 million or you know a
billion points and you just try to do a
scatter plot of all those points you
know well one of your problems of course
is that you don't want to send 100
million points to the browser that's not
going to be a fun day but even if you
could it's not the right thing to do
from sort of a visualization perspective
right because you're going to get a lot
of overplotting and it's just not going
to be useful and so what can we do about
that well uh Jim bedar and his team have
worked on this data Shader project used
to be called abstract rendering sort of
initial conception of it but the idea is
to be able to do uh a perceptually
accurate rasterization very efficiently
uh and then send a low bandwidth image
to the browser and so this is an example
of that you can see it doing some of
work with the Census Data the New York
Taxi data shaded by uh reported race um
Jim has some nice benchmarks using the
2.8 billion points at um osm street map
data as well but just for a quick
example here it also integrates really
nice with okay so that's the the sort of
the point that I want to drive home uh
right here I've created a 100 million
point sorry actually 10 million point
data set this just has four sort of
distributed gaussians uh but we have
this interactive image at the end that
you know one it can draw this Fair
quickly but if we go ahead and zoom in
what's nice is that we get progressive
level uh Progressive refinement right so
this is 10 million points and this is
just on my laptop right so we can sort
of zoom in and really see the fine
levels of detail we start to get to the
levels of individual points this is a
really interesting demonstration with
the sensus data which I just don't
happen to have loaded on my laptop uh
there's this Census Data explorer that
you zoom into individual neighborhoods
and you start seeing you know not just
the aggregate behavior when you're
zoomed out but actually the individual
you know data reporting points uh at
whatever level you want so anyway so
that's I think a nice thing again
there's a tutorial on this uh Jim's
notebooks are very uh expository and
have a lot of explanatory texts that
talk about exactly what's going on so I
definitely recommend checking those out
if you have
time okay so that is just again some
overviews some demos something to w your
appetite um we're going to talk a little
bit about some Basics at first and then
we're going to dive into sort of layouts
and interactions and and Bokey
applications for most of the uh tutorial
but before diving into that I guess I
want to pause and see is everyone set up
has everyone got things installed any
issues any questions I can
answer okay all right well good um I
guess it's a it's a good sign that
things are getting easier and easier to
install um great Okay so The Notebook
that we're going to look at uh is this
uh number two basic plotting interface
so you should download that one locally
so you can go to it on nbv or.org if you
just want to sort of follow along and
look at it if you actually want to run
code you want to download that notebook
uh and then run uh Jupiter Jupiter
Notebook on it or IPython notebook on
that file does anyone have any questions
about how to get that notebook file
running
locally okay in that case let's take a
look at
it okay so um as I mentioned before
bokeh has sort of a layered approach to
apis there's a bokeh do models interface
that's a very lowlevel sort of building
blocks you can imagine a bunch of Legos
that you can put together in whatever
order you want it's the most expressive
and the most you know sophisticated but
it's also maybe the most uh you know
verose right and it's also possible to
put things together in ways that don't
always make sense right so um you know
but it it really is what mirrors the
python side to the JavaScript side
there's a corresponding set of objects
you know some models or things like axes
or data sources or you know labels or
you know ranges all of those things and
so everything on the python side is
mirrored into the browser as a as an
object in the browser as well uh and
that's how we synchronize everything up
and so it's possible to use that and
create really fantastic visualizations
again it's a little bit more work it's
sort of the most verbose layer um at the
other end of the spectrum there's a very
high level b. charts interface this is
the newest API probably the most
underdevelopment and and sort of the
most seen the most turn um uh it's
really the idea is to be able to do sort
of basic statistical computing uh in
very short order histograms violin
charts box plots uh you know all these
sort of things in sort of on liners and
get get images out very quickly um with
less work and sort of do lots of you
know lots of reasonable defaults right
uh and then in the middle uh and what
we're going to talk about here is the
Boke do plotting interface and that's
sort of my sweet spot that's pretty much
where I primarily go to some people
start with Boke dot models some people
you really love to use Bok do charts or
everything um badap potting is sort of
my happy place and so that's what we're
going to talk about today but it's sort
of the mid-level um around the same
level of specificity as sort of a mat
plot lib or mat lab or something like
that um and the whole idea is that you
want to be able to attach to basically
any visual primitive uh either sort of a
fixed value for it or a column of data
that comes from one of our column data
sources uh and then around that bokeh
will construct sort of a generic
reasonable default plot with default
axes and and you know default ranges and
things like that uh and so you can just
sort of throw data at these visual
shapes and get lots of interesting
things out so let's take a look at it
okay so the main things you're going be
using Imports that you're going to need
to use uh bad. plotting uh again from b.
we want to get output notebook in this
case uh and the show function um there's
also an output file function if you just
want to generate an HTML file um and
then if you want to uh embed things in
like a flask app or a Django app or
whatever there's a bokeh do embed do
components function that you can use to
get the right divs and and script tags
to do that but uh for this case for The
Notebook we're going to get output
notebook and we're going to also Al
import uh figure the figure function
from Boke up plotting right so we can
execute those sort of standard inputs
and that works great uh then we can
execute output notebook we can see that
sure enough BJs has loaded I'll mention
by default BJs loads from CDN it's also
possible to uh make inline to use inline
resources which would make a notebook
that's truly self-contained it would
have all the JavaScript of course it's
going be quite a bit bigger because it
has BJs Library embedded in it uh but it
would be completely self-contained you
could use it for instance you know
behind an airgap Network or anything
like that so okay so let's use badap
plot to create some basic scatter plot
so again we're going to have this one
sort of section of the tutorial that's
fairly basic and then we're going to
move on to some more sophisticated
things so we want to create a new figure
we want to create a new plot rather so
we use this figure function to do that
I'm going to give it some options things
like plot width plot height we can give
it other options there's options for you
know axis labels and uh you know the the
size of the the border that you want
that sort of thing we get this plot
object back and then we want to call p.
circle on it so p. circle is is a
function says I want to create a bunch
of circles uh and so in the simplest
case we can just pass lists python lists
of data in this case I'm just passing
passing some lists we could pass numpy
arrays we could pass pandas you know
data frame columns uh pretty much any
sequence will work uh and we'll go ahead
and get some circles out that we want to
give it some other parameters like size
equals 15 so size is a data space or or
sorry screen space unit this is how big
we want the circles to be uh we can
specify things like the the line color
The Fill color and the alpha for these
cires and then we call show and that's
what's actually going to show it as our
output and so we can see that sure
enough we get a bunch of circles since
I've specified a size which is in screen
space units then if I do things like
zooming in and out we'll see they don't
get bigger right because size and Screen
units is absolute right it's pixels
basically so they don't actually get
bigger as I zoom in and out um you also
notice though that again b. plotting
basically generates sort of a default
set of tools a default set of you know
sort of a nice AIS that auto ranges um
you can see there's sort of a save
button that lets us get a you know a PNG
out um I should add programmatic
headless saving of pgs and svgs is also
something we're finally inching towards
as well um hopefully using Chrome
headless uh which is also a new project
but we are we are working on that uh but
it's got things like a you know a pan
tool we can move around or you know box
Zoom tool all of those are just sort of
standard and work or reset tool here to
go back uh so anyway this sort of
standard set of tools standard axes uh
and the idea is you can throw these
glyphs up we call the glyphs so things
like markers scatter markers or you know
all the shapes and lines that we can
draw we call those glyphs and so in this
case you want to be able to throw glyphs
uh at a figure and that's what bad.
plotting is all about um you might
notice it also returned this thing
called a bokeh notebook handle since
we're in the in the notebook um that's
actually to be able to update plot sort
of in place and we'll see some examples
of that a little bit later uh in the
interactions category so there's a nice
push notebook function that if you're
working in the notebook you can really
easily sort of have you know I python
widgets uh update your plot
interactively as well so we'll take a
look at that a little bit later but
let's go ahead and and do a quick
exercise and we'll take a few minutes
for everyone to to sort of look at
things basically want to just copy and
paste this first example uh and instead
of using uh size let's see what happens
if we use a
radius for our
Circle and certainly if you want to
change some
other some other properties as well
whatever if you have some favorite
colors f brick is a go-to for me for
some reason not sure
why might be initially surprised by the
reactions but if you zoom out a bit you
might sort of see what's going
on
for
okay so what happened when we used
radius instead right so the first thing
is we just replace size with radius and
and we get our plot we're like whoa
what's going on here and and if we zoom
out we might get some idea of what's
going on well radiuses in DED space
units by default right so here I've set
a radius of 15 so we can see sure enough
we've got these really big circles that
sort of overlap quite a bit but they get
bigger or smaller as I zoom in and out
and that's because again they're scaled
to sort of data space units they're
scaled to the axes um so we can try some
smaller radius maybe 0 point you know
0.15 and we can see sure enough we've
got much smaller circles here and if we
were to measure sort of how big those
were we'd see that they're you know 0.15
in sort of data units and again if we
zoom in and out we'll see they get
bigger or smaller as we zoom in and out
and so that's sort of the distance or
difference between size and and
radius any questions about that
hopefully fairly straightforward
probably familiar to folks that have
already used
Bok there are a lot of other markers uh
Circle obviously one but there's you
know things like P do square right Fair
straightforward uh you can just call P
do square and then sure enough now we
get squares notice here that instead of
giving a fix size they actually given uh
an array and this is actually important
so again the whole notion about all of
these glyphs is that basically any
visual property that they have the you
know the XY position the size or radius
the um the you know the fill colors The
Fill Alphas all of these properties can
either be a fixed value or they can
refer to like a list or a sequence of
data and using the figure interface we
can pass in this an explicit you know uh
uh list like I've done here or numpy
array or whatever a little bit later on
we'll see how we can construct column
data sources ourselves and then we can
actually refer to the names of those
columns is another option or another way
of doing that but we'll see that a bit
later but so you know I can I can put in
this here if I were to change this to
you
know 10 here then sure enough now
they're all the same size so uh put that
back a lot of other markers uh you know
you can click on any of these sort of C
examples in the documentation um you
know Asis circles circles with x's and
Crosses triangles and inverted triangles
all of them standard things you would
expect from a plotting Library um so you
can sort of click on those and see you
know any of them um uh any of those are
available so quick exercise maybe we'll
just take again a few minutes for folks
to sort of take the code above and and
modify it a little bit and see you know
see what they can see go ahead and maybe
just take like two
minutes
one other thing to notice here actually
is notice that I put color instead of
line color or fill color that's just an
alias that the figure uh convenience
that figure accepts so if you do color
that will set both the line color and
the fill color right so it's just a
little short
hand or want to give a r color
yeah absolutely so uh in book it at
charts we'll do some of that
automatically for you uh book it at
plotting you can give a list of colors
another feature that's coming up pretty
soon um we've added some infrastructure
and plumbing for doing basically
Transformations so I mentioned you can
have a fixed value or a column of data
um it's actually now you can have a
transformation on a column of data as
well and so we have some examples that
do for instance Jitter uh but we haven't
quite hooked up a color mapper yet it'd
be pretty simple exercise so we should
do it very soon but that would let you
do color mapping on the client so you
would say I want to color map this
column of data using this palette and
then that would actually happen in the
browser uh so you wouldn't actually have
to send all the colors like you do now
so that's coming very soon um but that's
so that's a great question the question
was uh you know is it possible to sort
of send list of colors you can do that
explicitly um you know if I go here I
can say color
equals fire brick and blue and
yellow and and you can also do Hex codes
of course for colors
um is my favorite green color here and
what's a good last color um I guess gray
uh so here I've given a list of colors
for for the color argument and sure
enough they all show up different colors
right so so that's possible to do now
with badat plotting you just give the
list of colors that you want um badat
charts will sometimes do that for you if
you say I want a group by some you know
the color by some column it'll actually
do a group by and color each group
differently um and then very soon uh in
book at plotting you'll also just build
to say I want to color map this column
according to this this value in this
pallette so that's going good
question let's see some other maybe
other parameters here we can change we
can change the line width equals you
know four or something that's also in
screen units fairly straightforward
stuff but we can see that that makes you
know sort of thicker lines so again all
of those properties basically any of
those properties there can be uh fixed
values they can be uh Columns of data
sequences of data uh you know references
to columns um and again they can also be
um transforms on columns which we're not
going to talk a lot about today but
they're pretty cool I refer you to the
the Jitter example in in GitHub if
you're curious about that okay any
questions so
far
okay line plots probably want line plots
as well scatters are great um so there's
p. line
same idea you can give it uh you know
fixed value you can give it uh sequence
of data um you can specify things like
line width sure enough like all this and
I get a line out um nothing too
spectacular about that but you know it's
uh hopefully fairly straightforward
again nice default plot lets us have
that connected line images another glyph
we have is the image glyph right so in
this case um image we're going to use
the image rgba glyph which it actually
just accepts uh an array of rgba data so
if you just have literally rgba data you
can plot that here right and so this
this uses kind of some fancy numpy
indexing I'm not going to go into
details of that but it uses um some
fancy nump indexing to set the red green
blue and Alpha channels uh basically of
this array uh to create this image of
rgba values uh and then we pass that to
image rgba we get sure enough we get
this image and again we can sort of have
standard tools and we can zoom in and
out and all that works um fairly you
know fairly simply and
straightforwardly lot lot of other kind
of glyphs uh I'm not going to go into
too much detail here hopefully that
gives you the flavor of how to proceed
and you can look in the documentation
which has lots of examples both in in
the reference guide and also the user's
guide uh but of course there's things
like rectangles and ovals we actually
just added some really useful new ones
uh we added V bar and H bar right so
rectangles are sort of uh you you give a
center point and an angle and a width
and a height and and of course quads you
give you know top left right bottom if
you want to draw bars like if you
actually wanted to draw a stacked bar
chart using bad out plotting you kind of
want the hybrid of those right you want
to specify maybe a center
um and a width and then a top and a
bottom and so that's what V bar and H
bar give you and that was just added by
an outside contributor I'm really really
excited about sort of the increasing
pace of outside you know sort of new
cont contributions and new contributors
we're getting I think we've got 180
contributors on GitHub now um a lot of
those are sort of very small you know
PRS but we're starting to get bigger and
bigger PRS as well and so I'm I'm very
excited if you're looking for you know
an open source project to to sort of get
involved in we're always trying to be
extremely helpful and extremely
welcoming and and answer questions as
best we can so uh please don't be shy if
you're interested in contrib rting um so
that's those ones uh segments and Rays
uh wedges and arcs if you want to draw
of course like some kind of dnut chart
or pie chart we've got these you know
wedge and annular wedge and annulus kind
of glyphs and there's a few specialized
curves that um I haven't used myself
much but I'm always interested to see
what users come up with there's like a
bezier curve Cliff uh and a quadratic
cliff and someone added a nice um cord
chart using those recently again a new
contributor added those so actually
let's go ahead and take a few minutes if
folks want to click on some of these you
can go to some code examples but you can
run them here in the notebook um and
I'll just I'll pick one but you can pick
whatever you want we'll take just a
couple of minutes and maybe example take
a look at some examples so
actually here
to
okay see if I can't find
a a vbar
glyph
oh
interesting yes absolutely uh so yes so
you can you can set uh one which tools
you want at all on the toolbar and then
you can also set now and this was a
recent request that we added uh which
tools initially start out is active so
yes all of those are configurable from
python yes
yeah yeah oh good question so uh let's
see so actually this is a good point to
go you go to b. p.org is the
documentation site um we have a one we
have a reference guide that's sort of
generated automatically and you can go
and you can see all of sort of the
lowlevel information I mentioned we have
these things called models if you go to
like you know for the glyphs here let's
go to book it. models do glyphs and then
we can look at the the Circle 11 one you
can see some nice examples here in all
the reference stocks but you can see all
of the different properties that all of
these have so things like fi color line
Alpha line cap you know um all of the
things that the cliff has uh in
particular we can look at actually I
think it's b. markers would have Circle
yeah so there's the circle glyph so we
can see that it has either radius uh you
know or or size right because it's a
marker so it has size but it also has
this extra radius one because it's a
circle um and you can also specify
whether you know the radius units or
screen or data space things like that so
all of that's there let's see if we can
find the uh test my knowledge see if we
can find where the documentation for the
tools went so I think that would be in
the user guide and under configuring
plot
tools and if we go
to level
detail tools ah setting active tools
right so there's a whole section on
setting active tools here and the way
this works basically is uh plot itself
has a toolbar attribute and so you you
can say things like I want the the
active drag tool to be none I want the
active scroll tool to be Auto which is
just whatever Boke it would pick or you
can set it to a specific Tool uh and so
uh you know there's some examples of
that so anyway that's that's right there
in the users guide um we've tried to
make a really big push on our
documentation in the last you know well
18 months really but you know it's a big
job keeping up with things but I think
our users guide is is fairly
comprehensive we have a lot of inline uh
examples you know code with live plots
that were generated by that code so we
we generated we created some nice Sphinx
extensions for really helping us uh
create I think better documentation so
certainly though if you have any
suggestions on how to organize it or
make it more searchable uh or there's
something that's missing that you think
should be added we always welcome that
kind of feedback I will mention actually
now because this comes up um Google
itself seems to return a lot of old
results I'm not sure how to fix that um
but the actual site search is quite good
so if you go to things like column data
source uh here in the site search you'll
get back uh this nice thing that says I
want you know V12 12 results the 11
results or the latest results um and you
know you can see that it's only giving
me back relevant tools uh relevant
results so this is I would say if you're
looking to search the docs um you know
using keywords start with the actual
site search you'll probably have a
better result um the complaint that we
get sometimes is that if you just go to
Google and search for column data source
you'll get results for you know book a
0.9 or 0.8 or or whatever um this way
you'll always be able to get the the
version that you want okay uh so any
that was a good a good diversion uh so
thanks for that question all right so if
we go back to this I just want to run
this right quick um also just to give
you an idea since we're not going to
talk about bokeh do models but I at
least want to give you maybe a little
bit of an idea of what things look like
um this is sort of how things are much
again a little bit more complicated
right I have to create all the so this
this just to be clear this is an example
of using Boke out models but I wanted to
show those V bar glyphs um this is where
you would have to create the axis and
add it yourself and create you know a
grid and add that yourself and and sort
of create a document and and all of
those things but if we run it
uh oh we don't need
this in the
notebook this code actually wasn't meant
to be run in the notebook so I may be
out out of my uh here we don't need
documents PL
yeah okay well that may it actually work
so this code was written to not work run
the notebook uh and it had some sort of
fancy document stuff in and uh I may
have to restart my kernel to make that
work but anyway just to give you an idea
of what that level of specificity looks
like for the the book. models layer okay
um last sort of section here just want
to make it clear that you know because
we haven't done it explicitly it's
possible to combine as many glys as you
want on one plot right either with the
same data or different data so let's
take a look you know maybe we want to
have a line that actually has sort of
circles around it and I seem to have
gotten ah so creating that other
document restart my sorry creating that
document explicitly from that code that
I copied uh was was not a happy thing um
the Jupiter notebook's interesting and
challenging environment to run in just
because of the sort of way you can
affect sort of global State across cells
but anyway we'll restart
that uh and then ah we
go
yeah
ah so yeah so if we want to see multiple
glyphs together that's really easy right
so here I've just plotted uh a line with
some XY data in this case I've got X and
Y defined up here as some variables
these could be lists numpy arrays pandas
you know columns from data frames uh and
then again I plot a circle and so the
glyphs here are going to be plotted in
whatever order I provide them so the
lines plotted first the circles on top
you can see it uh sort of plots that way
again I've used the same data for both
of these but of course you could use
whatever you want you could plot
multiple circles with different sets of
data or whatever anything like that so
uh last little exercise here why don't
we let go ahead everyone uh sort of play
around with this yourself and make sure
things are working and
then that will be
good change this
up just as example we'll go ahead and
import
numpy NP so I have numpy installed uh we
can
NP so again perfectly fine for those
civy numpy arrays we could load some
data from pandas and and pass in pandas
as well pretty much any sequence
okay so that's pretty much the end of
this first section of the tutorial that
I wanted to go over um normally after
this we'd go into a section about sort
of styling visual attributes so again
there's lots of knobs and dials if you
want to change the the appearance of all
the ticks uh you know the the fonts and
the colors the way things are laid out
if you want to change the grid the axes
colors you know the title fonts pretty
much anything you would care to
configure you can so there's a whole
tutorial section about that there's a
lot of information in the user's guide
as well um we're going to skip over that
today just for the sake of expediency
but I just want to let yall know that
that's
there
and that's good we can actually just
take a quick look at that so yeah so if
we go to styling visual attributes just
to give you an idea of what's here here
um in case you want to go to it later
you can sort of see there's lots of
things you can configure you know um
things like the you know the the glyphs
themselves can be configured actually
this is something it's interesting if
you have selections it's possible to
control the appearance of selected and
unselected things so here if I click on
one I can I can specify exactly what
these selected and unselected glyphs
should look like um also hovers right so
if you want to specify like a hover
policy so here I've set a a hover tool
with a horizontal line for hit testing
and so you can see that the hovered you
know the hovered Cliffs that are hit by
that horizontal line get a a specific
policy and this tells you how to set
those kind of visuals as well uh again
axes you know if you want to control the
orientation or the size or the font or
whatever of the tick you can control
that here um you know if you want to
have differently colored fonts uh if you
have multiple axes maybe you have
multiple y axes uh and you want to have
different colored fonts for the axes to
specify different you know sort of
correspond to different lines of
different colors that's a pretty common
use case for that I think as
well
yes yeah absolutely so yeah yeah so here
the code here let's take a quick look so
yeah so we're taking I think we're doing
pretty good on time so I think it's
worth taking a brief diversion here
before moving on um the way that is
specified is you you call p. Circle just
like we did in the previous example uh
but here I can give not just fill color
or you know fill Alpha I can give hover
fill color right or hover line color
right and so in this case my hover line
color my hover fill color is fire brick
and my hover line color is white and you
can see that's exactly what I've got
here and so I've added a hover Tool uh
and the mode there h line means that it
should basically correspond to a
horizontal line uh wherever the cursor
is and so anything that's hit by that
horizontal line uh that'll be considered
hovered over and so you can see that it
just updates that so I haven't had to do
any kind of extra work to do that or
write any JavaScript to do that all of
that just sort of falls
out yeah yeah so here I've specifically
added a hover tool so you know there's a
set of default tools that plots have uh
when you use the v. plotting uh. figure
uh but you can also add specifically
customized tool this case I've added a
hover tool that I you know I don't want
any tool tips and I only wanted to look
at my circle renderer and I want it to
have this sort of horizontal hline hit
testing and so um you know you can you
can certainly explicitly add tools using
these uh lowle tool
models same thing and this is basically
the same interface for the selections
here I've given a non- selection you
know fill Alpha of 02 and a non-
selection fill color of gray and then a
uh selection color of fire brick and
sure enough if I if I select something
the selected one is you know sort of
filled fire brick and then the other
ones are sort of have an alpha and
filled gray and you know that works even
with multiple selection here so I've uh
you know I can use the shift key to do
multiple
selections anyway so again that's this
is a nice reference the user guide also
has a lot of examples like this um for
um most any of the uh sort of knobs and
dials that you might want to uh sort of
U change to change properties so any
questions about that though before we
move into the the next
chapter
okay
great then in that case let's go back
here
to plotting and we're going to go on to
chapter four which is interaction so
I'll give everyone just a moment to
download that from uh NB viewer so if
you're on NB viewer again you're going
to want to go to chapter 4 uh there's
that nice download button in the upper
rightand corner uh and then you can run
jupyter notebook or IPython notebook on
that file and then you can actually
execute code locally
uh and or if you just want to if you're
just on nbv you can sort of follow along
and look at what's there those and those
rendered static notebooks but uh if you
want to execute code definitely download
it locally
so give everyone just a minute to do
that and then we'll probably do one
exercise and then take a
break this font big enough by the way
make this bigger
that better it's probably better
okay I can just make this bigger as well
okay so this next section uh is about
sort of layouts and widgets interactions
they all kind of go together in order to
have widgets you need to have a layout
to be able to lay things out together uh
and then typically if you want
interactions there in response to things
like Widgets or tools and so all kind of
goes together and so we're going to
start with layouts and then we're going
to move on to how you can get some
really nice and interesting and
sophisticated interactions in bokeh
doents so again our standard Imports
here output notebook and show from from
b. we call output notebook uh you can
see it's loaded that's great so the
first layout I want to look at is called
grid plot so there's a module called b.
layout you can import grid plot from it
right up here um again this example is
going to be using uh b. plotting to
create a figure and actually we're going
to create several figures right so here
I'm creating some X values some some y
values uh basically I'm creating a sort
of a straight line in different
directions and then I'm creating an sort
of an absolute value you know just using
list comprehensions in Python again
could be numpy arrays or pandas columns
whatever you want and then I'm going to
create three plots right so I'm creating
S1 S2 and S3 so I call figure three
times I give it you know in this case I
want sort of smaller plots so I give it
sort of plot width and plot height
smaller um I create the first one with
circles with X and y0 the second one
with triangles X and y1 is the
coordinates and the last one with
squares with X and Y2 as the coordinates
uh and again I can you know set all
those properties however I want I could
have an array of color or an array of
Alphas or whatever I would you know any
of these could be vectorized um in this
case I've given single values and then I
want to put them in a row so I call this
grid plot function and I can basically
give a nested list of lists of layouts
so if you're familiar with sort of uh
other layout functions I think it's
fairly similar um it's I've got the
outer one says that I've you know I've
got sort of one column here and then in
my column I've got one row that's this
inner list and in that row I want S1 S2
and S3 that's sort of how that nesting
structure works out and so I create that
from grid plot that gives me the this
good plot thing and then I can call show
on it and sure enough I get three plots
right and all of these are
independent uh you know I can move this
around um note that on grid plot I've
also specified toolbar location equals
none if I wanted a toolbar by by default
grid plot tries to coales the toolbar so
if I wanted a toolbar I could add it and
I would get one toolbar and basically
this control is the active tool for all
the plot so I could you know I could
change this to wheel zoom and now they
all have a wheel Zoom active um I can
hit reset um you know I can change it to
box zoom and now they have box Zoom
active and so it really just it just
depends uh on how you want but that grid
plot that toolbar location will let you
not have a toolbar if you don't want it
okay so first exercise and then let's
take a break uh which is just to sort of
create your own grid plot create a
couple of plots and put it in a grid
plot maybe let's create two grid plots
or two plots and put them in a grid plot
again you can sort of probably start by
copying and pasting if you want but you
might have some more interesting data
that you'd like to put in maybe you have
some local data that you want to plot um
see what I can create here with
numpy
for
not make those so
big can also of course put
those
column if we wanted to we'll in a minute
there's an easier way to make columns
but you can certainly do columns using
grid plot as
well so here I've created uh now here's
my outer parentheses specify column you
know a column and and within that column
there's one row another row and another
row okay so what have I done here so
again I just switched to using some nump
and you might have some more interesting
data locally that you want to look at um
here I just created uh you know y x yal
sin of X and yal absolute value of x
uh and again I can put those in a grid
plot and I can use that to make a column
um I could do something like this as
well if I wanted something a little bit
more different
looking right so here you know it's very
flexible if you want to have one on the
top row and and you know two on the
bottom that's certainly fine so there's
one one plot in this first row and then
two plots in the second row so that's
sort of the flexible way to combine and
and put things
together okay so that was actually the
second exercise as well the stacking
vertically so before we get to length
interactions which is actually I think
probably something getting a little bit
more interesting uh why don't we go
ahead and again take a quick break five
minutes or so I have 5 till three so
let's or 5 till four rather so let's
reconvene right at right at 4 or so uh
just give everyone a break if you want
to get a drink of water or coffee uh and
then we'll get started again in about
five
minutes certainly happy to answer any
questions of course during the break if
people have
questions
M yes the questions about the
spectrogram yeah it's in the GitHub repo
um it's uh it's under examples so yeah
so let me actually maybe I can show
people the GitHub repo while we're sort
of taking a little break if we go to
bokeh or
GitHub Boke so if you go to
examples uh in this case it's app and
you can see there's quite a few so that
cross filter almost everything that's
everything that's on that demo. plots.
site is in here plus a few extra ones
like the streaming ohlc ticker and then
also the spect as well so yeah
spectrogram is
done sorry yeah so it's it's bokeb so
github.com
is that so you're familiar with
GitHub
okay okay and I just interviewed a guy
from one of the guys
who okay yeah no I yeah quite possibly
yeah I I I I've done uh podcast on it
and so I'm happy yeah I'm happy to do an
interview yeah my card is on the table
if you want to grab one of
mys but you also bring edit an example
uh and I iatch up with you okay um so
this one you show me the absolutely yeah
so
absolutely yeah I know so it's just way
the next thing is you know in this case
for the outer colum got a row one plot
and a row that has two plots and so
we'll see some other ways to layouts
here in midle but U I was interested you
had the think you Chang uh I just I just
used yeah I just used numpy so just to
show that you can use numpy so numpy is
just a ray liary for python yeah and so
I just wanted to show perfectly fine
using nump arrays as the as the values
for X and Y like that um
very okay yeah you might definitely
interested in my data project as well
ini just looking at that and that's also
it's in the bouet organization it's
bouet data sh okay so yeah it's a
different it's a separate project but
it's sort of under the B umbrella
organization so yeah I'll get great
thank
you that but let's I make these plots
how do iord them to
yeah so that's that's what we're working
on right now is that static so right now
you can use a save button and generate a
PNG uh but headless generation without a
browser
is no that would just be yeah
so as far as I know like I don't think
power lets you Ed like anything let you
embed JavaScript you're fine um but if
it doesn't have embeddable JavaScript
then have to use an
IP or or just a web page right I mean
you can serve it from flask right you
don't the notebook's convenient for
teach
yeah yeah and actually that that would
work fine so Co quick question um can't
believe I have to ask you this um
charge how do I get layout size layout
just that the square box uh I think
there's a default St let's talk about it
afterward I don't know off hand yeah I I
don't yeah SAR size shap with I Fabi I
think I tried doing a figure and then
that
didn't I just want to call bar and I
want
to yeah to the plot ifot there's there's
there's like a from charts import
defaults so this is something that Nick
came up with um it doesn't used elare
but I think you can give a plot width
and a plot height on charts. defaults so
if you do from book it. charts import
defaults there's like default do either
with
Ora I see you might just try if just try
take a look you can ask faio might know
too yeah hi my name is hi nice to meet
you ask you this question about this is
mostly about creating Graal web apps
right yes
so everything own MH well it's h so B
generates HTML and JavaScript right it
well so creates uh well actually the
python Library creates uh a Json really
is the main output uh and then there's a
library JavaScript library called BJs
that can consume that JavaScript and
generate plots on in the browser right
and so you know you can generate HTML
files using output file you can generate
in the browser and I you know Jupiter
notebook um you can use the embedding
Library the embedding apis to do like
flask or Jango and have web pages that
have things embedded like all of this
you know for instance all of this uh
documentation right if we go to the
documentation and we go to the user
guide we can go to you know styling
visual attributes all of these plots are
um there's a lot of it it's going to
take a while to load sorry um all of
these are embedded boki plots but
they're live plots right these are
actually you know this is you know I can
I can pan you know pan this around right
and this is the code that generated it
but it generated some you know some a
div in a script tag that got embedded
here and that's what creates the plot
and so so that's and and so that's for
sort of Standalone documents and we'll
come to the book a server in just a
minute um does it make sense I don't
know if my next question or not is it
possible I have
very in iOS or
Swift um so quite Poss so well so the
thing is there's no to my knowledge no
one's written like a a swift or objectiv
C binding but the thing is you can
actually you could write it in Python
export the Json and then you could use
that that's certainly doable yeah that I
mean that's a little bit more roundabout
we could maybe make it easier I know
there's something between the Python and
The Objective C but the question I and
then I Json from Json I can use it with
yeah there's because there's actually an
autoload static function that just takes
that Json and just loads it right and so
you could do that you could create the
Json with python and having done that
then you could use it in a swift or IOS
app so this is a question I want to know
for you what's the difference between
what you're doing in Python for what's
the addition so it seems to me like you
have gred everything from python but you
added to it so if I go
to um so like I said the the main
flexibility the main idea was to make it
very coupl in flexible where there's
this completely separate runtime in in
JavaScript that takes a a declarative
interface like the python doesn't
generate code it generates this Json
Declaration of what the plot should be
and so again any language that can
generate the right Json can make those
plots so you could actually you could
imagine writing Swift or iOS to generate
the right Json directly I'd love to see
that project that's that's a bit of an
undertaking to do it in general you know
but someone's done that for R Boke
someone's made a b. Scala that generates
the right Json so you can use Scala to
generate Boke plots or R to generate Bok
plots um but uh you don't lose anything
by going from python saying the python
binding is very complete and pretty much
anything you can do with pojs you can do
from python you see this is if I don't
want to rewrite everything if I want to
use the
books Never from that then in that Cas
have to go back and
recre in Python yeah
yeah there is yeah and there is also
well so there is a new uh JavaScript API
directly so if you also just wanted to
Target the JavaScript API um we this is
very new so I don't have a lot to show
you about it yet but so this is a
question because I don't want
toite
just of course it's faster it's
better but at the same don't want to so
is things are things updating I mean are
is is it a case you can sort of generate
the plot once uh and then it's sort of
fixed or you need to update things yeah
you need okay let's have a discussion
after let me get started again on this
but yeah please come find me let's have
a longer discussion right after the
tutorial excellent great this is really
inant Cas so I'd love I'd love to talk
about it more excellent all right uh
welcome back everybody I think we're
probably ready to get going for the next
section uh hope everyone have a nice
little break
um two two hours and a quarter is kind
of a long time to to sit so hopefully
that's good to stretch your legs Okay so
so we saw how we can take these Bouy
plots that we can create we can put them
in layouts like GD you know grid plot or
uh you know whatever there's also uh
let's see
here there's also something called
column let me go ahead and show that off
right quick as well just before moving
on so in addition to grid plot there is
row and
column and so you can do things like
row and here I can just give a list of
plots
and that's just an easier way to
generate a row note that uh you know
again the tool bars there are not uh
collaps column also
here will generate a column of plots so
there you go uh anyway so the next thing
though the reason that this is nice sort
of setup is that we want to talk about
how to have linked interactions in Boke
Plaza so there's all kinds of things you
can do using the voke server or
callbacks that we'll see pretty soon
here but it's actually possible to do a
lot without any writing any sort of you
know code to just do things very
declaratively want to make it very easy
in um B it to have things like linked
panning so if you pan one plot another
one can move correspondingly or linked
brushing if you make a selection on one
plot to see the corresponding things uh
linked and so those are very easy to
express in bokane so you do that um by
sharing things basically so let's talk
about linked panning first let's say we
want to have some plots that uh work
together uh and then if we pan one that
we see the other ones pan as well so
here I create my grid plot but what have
I done differently when I create these
plots so the plots have an attribute
called X range and Y range and these are
normally created by default by figure
and they're also created in a in a way
that they sort of Auto Range you to
whatever the shape of the data is it
tries to sort of show all the data at
once uh and that's the default but it's
possible to share ranges between plots
so look what I've done here I've on my
second plot I've set its X range equal
to the X range from the first plot and
I've also set it's y range equal to the
Y range from the first plot
and for the third one I've only shared
the X range I haven't shared the Y range
but I've given it the same X range at
the first plot and the second plot has
and so if I execute this code and I run
it what's going to happen well the first
two plots are linked in both axes
whereas that last plot is only linked in
you know in the uh in the last axis
there so that's it's very easy so I mean
there's all kinds of other additional
interactions that we can do we'll see in
a little bit where we can use like
customjs callbacks or we can use Python
callbacks in the server but uh getting
this kind of basic linked interaction is
fairly straightforward without writing
any actual code to do it we just you
know if we want to share uh axes we want
to share this panning we can just share
the ranges that control that direction
and it's very easy to
do same thing if we were to zoom in and
out uh we would see the zooming Behavior
behave the same as well
okay all right so exercise here was to
create two plots in a good plot let's go
ahead and do that so if we do from bokeh
and I'll let everyone here do that as
well but plotting
import uh figure and from
bokeh.io
Import
Show and from b. layouts import grid
plot all right so I can say something
like
P0
figure let's give it a plot
width 250 and a plot
height
and we'll want P1 to be pretty similar
to
that and let's do p 0.
Circle
some sort of fake data there and we can
do the same thing
for
P1 right and then we put those in a grid
plot right layout equals grid
plot
and I want to share the ranges here so
here let's just share the X range and
not the Y range so we say something like
X range equals p0x
range and then we want to
show the
layout I forget here oh I misspelled
grid flot
and not P2 p 0 and
P1 great and so if we actually look at
those then sure enough they share the X
range and so we have that linked panning
behavior on the X Direction uh but not
on the y direction because we didn't
share the Y
range any questions about linked
panning show that kind of Link
interaction um we'll talk about how to
do other things um in reaction to sort
of um pan or or range change events too
there's this whole notion of adding sort
of short small customjs callbacks and
you can attach those to for instance
range changes so that when the range
changes you can do all kinds of uh fancy
things so uh next though linked brushing
so link brushing is really uh the idea
that you want to highlight things in a
similar manner across different plots so
in particular if we make a selection on
one plot using a lasso tool or a box
select tool or something like that uh
can we highlight the corresponding
points you know data points in another
plot and again bokeh makes that very
easy to express by just using a sharing
notion right so under the covers um the
fundamental sort of uh most common data
transport structure that bokeh use this
is something called a column data source
this is sometimes a source of confusion
um I'll say sort of very simply that
it's a a fairly basic data structure
it's a basically dictionary that Maps
string names to sequences of data it's
kind of like a a cheap data frame right
we didn't want bokeh to depend on pandas
um at the core level we wanted to make
it sort of as as depend pendency free as
possible and we also had some other
reasons as well so we made this column
data source and again it's just uh it's
just a basically a dictionary that has
sort of named columns and the columns
have to be the same length and that's it
so we can create that ourselves we
haven't done that yet but let's do that
in this example let's take a look at it
so I I I import colum data source from
b.
models I create some X data and some y z
and y1 data again it's just python lists
in this case we could have numpy arrays
pandas columns whatever we want I create
my column data source object and here
it's exactly what I say says it is I
create a dictionary and I can set you
know the X key equal to the X column of
data and the y z key equal to that y0
column of data and the y1 key equal to
that y1 list of data and so this is just
a uh you know just a um actually let's
go ahead and split this cell if I go to
we can take a look at it if I split the
cell and I execute this uh and then I
say something like uh print source. dat
right you can see exactly what it is
it's a dictionary that has a list of
data for y1 and a list of data for y z
it's very simple data structure that's
all a column data source is is basically
this with some other things around it so
we can create those explicitly and if we
do
that um then when we create our glyphs
we can tell it specifically I want to
use this column data source or that
column data source so first we're going
to ahead and create a plot um someone
also asked earlier about specifying
tools here's one way that you can
specify what tools a plot should have
right I just give it a list sort of a
comma separated string that says I want
box select tool and a lasso select tool
and the help tool and I can pass that as
the tools argument to figure so that's
one thing there so I create my figure
and then I call uh Circle and instead of
giving it the
actual uh you know uh list of data here
or array of data here I give it the name
of the column that I want to use so I
want to use the X column for the x value
and the y0o column and I want to take
those from my data source that I created
up above and so I pass the
source uh argument to figure as the data
source that I just created up here let's
actually rename this make it a little
bit more obvious so I'm going to call
that DS so I can say Source equals DS
and Source equals DS here and the thing
to note is that I've given both this
left and right plot I've given them the
same data source so if I have two plots
that share a data source that means that
by default selections on one will be
mirrored as selections on the other and
so let's take a look at what that
actually looks like right so here I've
got my two plots I can create my box
select tool I can select these points
and sure enough the selection
automatically is mirrored in the other
plot now sometimes you have more
sophisticated things where you have like
one to many selections and we can sort
of see some examples of how to do that
with uh customjs callbacks but if you
have you know data shared between plots
like this and you want to just have the
selections mirrored it's very easy to do
again without writing sort of code to do
that you just share the data source and
that just sort of falls out
naturally okay so
yes to No Yeah so basically the way that
the transport works for V is that uh
every model object is sent and so in
this case there's one uh data source uh
that's shared between objects and this
was a little bit of a fun implementation
challenge uh we had to basically create
something a to pointers in our protocol
that could be used to create an object
once on the JavaScript side and then
actually share it among on multiple uh
plots for instance but that's yeah in
this case the one data source is sent uh
and then that's the reason it works is
because it's actually shared between the
plots so if I make a selection here it
doesn't matter if I make a selection on
this side it's mirrored on the right
side the two plots share those data
sources so we wanted to make that kind
of interaction very easy to express um
more things as well but
okay so I do actually want to get to the
fun stuff so let's go ahead and skip
this exercise if that's okay I think
hopefully everyone has a pretty good
idea um another nice interaction that's
fairly easy to spell in in bokeh is to
have sort of interactive hover tools for
sort of drill down you know as I
mentioned when you create your own
column data source you can give it you
know The Columns of data that you want
to drive for instance the coordinates X
or Y you could create a column to drive
the fill colors or the you know the line
widths or whatever you want but you can
also put in extra data that doesn't
actually correspond to anything on the
glyph and the reason you might want to
do that is because you might want to
have a hover tool that can show data
from that column so let's take a a look
at that concretely here I create a
column data source again I give it my
dictionary here I've got some X values
I've got some y values and then I've
just got some other column called
description or desk and it's just got
some strings in it you know it could be
part numbers or uh tags or something
whatever it doesn't actually it's not
going to get used to draw any of the
glyphs in book in uh in the plot but we
want to be able to use it to sort of
maybe show up in a hover tool so what
does that look like so we actually
create a hover tool again I've imported
hover tool from book it up models and I
can pass it this tool tips and the way
tool tips works is you give it a list of
tupal that have a sort of a field name
and this is what's going to show up in
the tool tip um index XY and desk and
then I can refer to columns so if I want
to see the the corresponding value from
that description column I can say at
desk there's this little language that's
described in the docs um you know at Fu
shows whatever uh whatever from the fu
column right so in this case I want to
see the value from this description
column in the hover tool tip so I create
my plot give it a title here I I say
that you know the circles should be at X
and Y I want to give it this data source
I've created uh and and then I hover
with DOs and sure enough I get I think
we got a little CSS issue mastering to
fix I'm not sure why those uh sort of
table lines are there but you can see
it's got the description right for every
one that I'm hover hover over I've got
the corresponding description showing
up all right so this is point a you know
this one over here is point e uh and so
we're able to have these nice columns
it's also possible to have a custom
hover tool tip uh basically you can
supply a template um HTML style template
so if you want to have sort of a more
fancy tool tip you can definitely do
that here um in this case we've actually
got a column that uh loads a an image
you know the tool tip actually has an
image uh in the template and so you can
actually have images show up we aren't
quite at the level where we can have a
bouquet plot in the hover tool tip
someone asked about that recently and I
I sort of made a stab at it um that
would be really awesome I think um we're
not quite there yet that's probably
something we can do pretty soon but uh
anyway so this is the hover tool tip you
can use that to be able to hover over
all kinds of things um you can see more
examples of that in the docs if we got
to bcp.org we can go
to the users guide and there's a whole
section on adding interactions in here
um and so if we go there we can go
to see linking plot
where would that be we just reorganized
this sorry
um actually I think covers are going to
be under configuring plot tools sorry
configuring plot tools yeah so here we
have um you know hover tools and we can
talk about you know basic tool tips as
well as you know here's what a custom
tool tip looks like it's basically just
HTML that has you know things like you
know at you know at whatever column I
want and it just shows up
so uh also if we go to the
gallery I think there's an example in
there as well as well another thing to
mention so in addition to the users
guide and the reference guide by the way
there's also a gallery which I would
like to start adding we have some new
examples that we haven't added here yet
but um it's still quite good at the
moment we're going to be adding more to
that as well IDE is you know uh people
learn in different ways I think and so
sometimes like for me I just go look in
the gallery and say hey what looks kind
of like what I want you know and I go
find it uh and then I can sort of see
the code and so all of these are live
you know this is an example of showing
those Jitter Transformations and um so
you can sort of see an example hover
works with things like patches right so
here's a
map of Texas and some unemployment from
2009 and uh see it's quite Snappy on
those patch the counties of Texas right
so um anyway good
stuff all right uh there we go so that's
that's hovers um another type of
interaction you might want to do is in
the Jupiter notebook itself um so in
addition so bokeh has a basically a set
of built-in sort of widgets you can use
and as as we've seen with sort of custom
extensions you can wrap other JavaScript
widget libraries if you wanted to um
Jupiter has its own set of widgets that
are built in uh and so we can actually
use those really well with um one
particular function called push notebook
that lets us update a plot in place and
so let's take a look at what that might
look like so here I've got my standard
Imports um I'm using numpy to create
some X and Y data I put that in a column
data source uh I create a figure I
create a line with X and Y I give it the
the source here and now here's what I I
python or Jupiter does right I create
this function called
update um um it takes an argument which
in this case is going to be a string as
well as sort of an Omega and amplitude
here and a fi um to control the
parameters of a sine wave here and you
can see what the function does if you
know if f is sign then it computes a
sign if f is cosine it computes np.
cosine if it's tangent it computes np.
tangent um and then what it does is it
computes new y values for you know
whatever whatever the parameters that
got passed update it computes a whole
new set of Y values and it sets that to
Source data so Source data sub y it's my
y values it updates them and then it
calls push notebook and that's where the
magic is right so push notebook uh is
what causes the inline plot to update so
let's go ahead and run this I want to
show my plot uh and then the last little
bit here this is from IPI widgets so IPI
widgets is a separate Library outside of
bokeh it's sort of part of the Jupiter
project I want to call interact and so
when I call interact I wanted to use my
update function
and then I get a list of all the values
here's a list of you know the values for
a drop down here's a list of slider
values for the uh w a and F things and
when I run
this Jupiter just automatically sort of
automatically creates this little gooey
for me and sure enough if I change this
W then the plot updates right uh or
change the amplitude or if I change the
phase there or you know if I select
cosine then it's going to give me the
cosine or the tangent or whatever and so
again the the magic that makes this
happen is in my update function I'm able
to update the Y values in my data source
and then to actually have the the same
plot that's already drawn get updated in
place I call Push notebook and so this
doesn't redraw the entire plot uh it
just causes you know or recreate the
entire plot uh it very efficiently just
sends this this one set of data that
changed and then it causes the uh you
know the redraw to update the the actual
line that's drawn there so that's a
really nice sort of uh capability if you
work a lot in the Jupiter notebook uh
this can be very
useful dat is
destroy so what is sent is basically
like a patch message that says patch the
data source with this new column and it
gives the new the new yv values so I
don't want to go too much into the sort
of the lowlevel details but there's
basically a protocol that can support uh
updating attributes on these models and
so in this case you can say I want to
update the data attribute uh and so it
sends yeah it sends this data attribute
over and it replaces the data value but
everything else that was previously sent
all the AIS objects all the you know po
itself the tool tools none of that has
to be recreated it's just the just the
data yeah exactly right yeah the idea is
that it's just it's just just sort of
patching just the part that changed
right and so push notebook can keep
track of of what changed and and send
just that that bit that
changed okay so again that uses this IPI
widget so if you want if you want that
to work you'll also need to condom or
pip install IPI widgets so I think I
forgot to mention that earlier on this
is the the one example that uses that
but um the main thing there is this
interact
function so you give it you give it a
call back and then you give it basically
what you want all the parameters for
that call back to to be represented by
so a list of strings is going to give us
a drop down like this whereas T PS like
this are going to give us a slider and
you can see that it's got a slider for
you know w a and fi um because we gave
it two
PS and then whenever you change the
slider it will call that update function
for you so that's how that sort of all
gets put
together okay so uh as I mentioned bokeh
also has its own set of widgets um that
you can use either in the notebook but
you can also use in you know bokeh
applications or or Standalone bokeh
documents outside the notebook too right
so that's the main reason we created our
own widget section widget uh sort of
collection is because we wanted to have
one more kinds of widgets than are
offered by The jupyter Notebook but we
also wanted things that could work
outside the jupyter notebook and so
that's sort of an important thing for us
so let's take a look at what that looks
like let's say we want to create our own
slider excuse me um um so I import
slider from book it. models. widgets it
has the kind of parameters you might
expect a start and end value start and
an end point it's got a a value where
you know it should start a step size and
maybe a title I'm going to put this in
something called a widget box and then
I'm going to show that all right and so
that's going to give me the slider and
sure enough I can just see that I've got
a slider in and you know by itself it
doesn't do anything it just creates the
slider for me I haven't hooked it up to
anything um we'll see in a bit that we
can hook it up to uh both uh python code
using a bokeh server or we can hook it
up to little little tiny Snippets of
JavaScript using customjs callback so
we'll see that in a second we'll go
ahead and refer everyone to this adding
widget
section uh in the users guide uh and if
you do that you can see lots of
different all the basically all the you
know kinds of widgets there are uh you
can see examples here an example code so
let's take a minute to actually do an
exercise and then uh we can add a wanted
to have us add it was a a select widget
right so it'll take two minutes we'll
add a select widget
uh yes the question is about
communication between widgets um in the
Standalone document with customjs
callbacks basically whenever the widget
is updated that triggers a a JavaScript
call back that you can supply uh and in
the BOK server case it's basically any
property change uh triggers a can
trigger a call back on the python side
and so you could have the same call back
for multiple widgets if you want that um
but when you scrub the slider that
causes like the value property to change
and so then that will trigger a call
back in the server code I
CR oh and you want to change yes yeah
you want to change the options yeah you
can ABS you can certainly change the
options in One widget based on the other
widget you'd have to write a call back
that does that yeah but but yeah you
would say select two. options equals
some new list of options and then that
the act of doing that would cause the
the other one's update yeah very good
question okay all right so I'm just
going to copy this select code here and
then we can talk about it
um exercise here so again I've imported
uh widget box and I've imported
select I don't want to do output file um
select takes things like a title uh an
initial value that you want as well as
the option so who here I've given it you
know Fubar baz quux and and if I I do
that sure enough I get it and I've got
my widget so again what can we do with
these widgets that's great we can create
these widgets right now they're not
hooked up to anything they're just sort
of there um so you actually want to do
something interesting again the two ways
and we'll see both here before we leave
today are customjs callbacks and the
server so let's quickly go through some
customjs callbacks and then we're going
to sort of pivot over to talk about the
bouet
server okay so here
is a caned sort of customjs call back
there's something called uh well
actually sorry I lied there here's a
customjs call back U and I give it some
JavaScript code what is the JavaScript
code it just says alert Hello World um
I'm attached this call back to a tap
tool and so what that means is that
whenever I get a a tap selection it's
going to call this little bit of
JavaScript right so if I do this here
sure enough right I clicked on a circle
uh whenever the selection happens from a
tap tool that's when the call back gets
called uh and it calls you know alert
hello world but we can imagine doing a
lot more interesting things so there's
actually a lot of places to put uh
callbacks on you can put them on
basically any sort of widget change if a
slider is scrubbed or if a drop down
changes you can put them on lots of
tools like box select tools or lasso
tools or hover tools um you can put them
on selection so when the selection
changes on a on a column data source you
can do that and finally you can put them
on ranges so if the r you know the pan
or zoom and the range changes you can
you can do respond to that as well so if
we actually want to take a look at one
that has a widget let's run this code
and then I'll talk about it right so
here I've created in a layout I've
created a slider as well as a plot and
if I scrub the slider we can see sure
enough the the Y values for this update
right so what's going on so how do we
make that happen so this is a little bit
of a compromise you know I originally
said at the beginning no JavaScript but
we did realize um as we were still
working on the server and we wanted to
allow people to have capability that you
know if you're willing to have a little
bit of JavaScript here and there you can
actually use some really interesting and
sophisticated things and so this is an
example you know you can do with you
know five or six lines of JavaScript you
can make Standalone documents that are
just HTML and JavaScript no server um
that are still quite richly interactive
and so what do we do here so again I
create some data X and Y uh I put that
in a column data source I create a plot
with a line all of that we've seen so
far um at the bottom here I'm creating
my slider uh I put my slider in the plot
in a column and then I show that layout
so that's everything we've seen so far
nothing new there except now you know
that you can put both widgets and plots
inside these layout functions right so
we can know before we only put plots in
the layouts but now we can also see that
it's perfectly fine to put widgets there
so what actually makes the widget do
something well I create this callback
this customjs callback and the code that
I want to give it uh well it says Okay I
want to get the the data attribute of my
source that I passed in I want to get
the the value from whatever the call
back object was in this case the call
back object is going to be uh the uh the
slider itself and so this gets that
value and then it gets the X and Y data
and then it Loops over it and it just
calls math.pow right so for whatever
each x value it calls math.pow with the
value of the slider as the as the
exponent uh and then it calls this
source. trigger. change and there's
actually a section a new section in the
user guide that explains a lot of what's
going on here uh in the JS API but
hopefully it's at least uh roughly sort
of in in general form uh apparent what's
going on here and sure enough when I
scrub the slider here the values for y
are you know whatever so this is you
know if I go to if I go to one I get a
straight line because it's just x to the
1 power if I go to two then this is
actually a bit of a Parabola right it's
going to be X2 or X cubed or whatever so
um yeah so anyway that's affords a lot
of different capabilities there um as I
mentioned it's also possible to have uh
callbacks on selections this one's a
little bit more sophisticated I'm not
sure I'm going to go through it in a lot
of detail but what it does is whenever
you make a selection it computes the
mean value the mean y value of all the
selected points and then it adjusts the
data source for that orange line so I
can you know see that the uh the line
will update you know to whatever that
mean value is so you could imagine
actually having to do something more
sophisticated it Compu a regression or
something you wanted um this even works
for distributed or uh disjoint
selections right I do that but the code
is up here it's a little bit more
sophisticated in this case it has to
look into that selection object and get
the selected indices and then compute
this this median right here um but
uh
um
youas um yeah people definitely do it
just depends um so right now we're still
currently working on improving the the
interaction of the bokeh server with the
notebook so now you have two sort of two
servers and so we're still working on
making that a little bit better I think
but people have definitely done a lot of
interesting things with uh you know with
customjs callbacks and in the notebook
in particular the the data Shader
example I show where the custom refin or
the progressive refinement happened when
I zoomed in on those 10 million points
uh that's due to something like like
this basically it sort of makes a full
loop there's actually a customjs
callback that calls the Jupiter
JavaScript API to execute python code
which causes the recomputation to happen
on the python side but you know it works
it works really well so it's it's
possible to a lot of interesting things
um and so one of the things though is
that um it's possible to encapsulate
this the the the the ability to make
those custom extensions means that we
can actually do this uh and not
necessarily have the JavaScript code
here but we can have it basically sort
of in an encapsulated form and say you
create your own model some new fancy
widget or fancy Tool uh and then you
just use it like any other Boke model
you can add your your Custom Tool or
your custom you know axis and it does
something special and the JavaScript
code is sort of hidden and again those
kind of extensions I want to make them
really easy for people to share uh if
you think of like again the atom you
know extension sort of uh uh browser
where you can load you know Community
contributions into atom that's exactly
what I want for bokeh because I think
it'll really uh M you know multiply and
amplify the value of those kind of
extensions if if the community can share
them them very easily so that's on the
The Fairly short-term Road for me to
road map for me to get done um if you
actually go to the documentation in the
users guide there's quite a few more
examples so I'll scroll up here to the
users guide and we go
to uh configuring plot
tools The Notebook adding interactions
there we go right so we go to JavaScript
callbacks uh subsection here and again
uh there's just a lot of examples here
so there's the one we just saw uh
there's also just one here sort of on a
custom tool that just draws you know I
want to draw a bunch of rectangles so
someone else recently on the mailing
list came in and had some really cool
use cases where they were using they
written a custom tool to let them
annotate things so they had a plot of
something and they wanted to be able to
select some region and then have that
inform some of their further computation
so that's exactly the kind of thing we
want people to be able to do and so they
didn't you know they wanted to have a
standalone document and so they used
custom JS callbacks for that here's
another example I just it just copies
the selection from one plot to the other
but you know you can imagine doing
something quite a bit more interesting
you know if you you know do whatever but
um
here's that same example with that
custom JS for hover right so here this
is if we wanted to have this sort of
mini to one relationship uh you know we
can do a callback on a hover that can
sort of draw the lines just when I hover
over it right this is something more
sophisticated than you can do with just
the hover policy right because we need
to draw these multiple lines for the
hover but uh the custom DS callback
would let us do that uh range update as
well um you know here if I zoom in to
this plot I can sort of show in the
other plot here you know where I'm
Zoomed In by the way when I'm zooming in
you might notice that the plot gets
decimated um that's something called
level of detail downsampling it's also
controllable uh basically it's just
while uh interactive events are
happening it'll down sample the data
automatically so that the responsive you
know the response rate is sort of kept
up to date uh or kept efficient um so
that it's very it's very responsive
right so anyway that's an example of
what you can do you can have callbacks
on on those last thing to mention here
this is kind of cool um allar Cent added
support for this it's actually possible
to write the Callback code in sort of
python for Customs callbacks um he has a
transpiler python to JavaScript uh and
it's a little weird because you always
have to bear in mind it's not running
python in your browser um but it's
compiling this python or transpiling
this python to JavaScript and so here
I've actually written the Callback in
Python and you can see exactly what it
does it just you know
math.pow uh and then I call this
customjs from PI function and I give it
the call back and it actually just
generates it and that generates a
customjs call back it generates the
JavaScript I have mixed feelings on this
um it's really cool and it's really
awesome but you also do have to remember
that it's not quite python you have to
know for instance that I need to call
window. math.pow because that's the
actual JavaScript function that has to
be called so it's you know transpilation
is a little strange sometimes but it can
be useful and people will certainly use
that as well okay so uh making sure we
have time to talk about the bokeh server
I think that's the end of that section
but before we
start
um I mean so you can put whatever
JavaScript you want in the customjs call
back so if you wanted to make an Ajax
call you could um I haven't done it
personally
but yeah absolutely could yeah I think
so I I haven't done that myself but I
don't
see yeah you would so you would you
would construct whatever Ajax you know
in the call back you would construct
whatever agx call you need and you would
presumably give it uh the call back when
it returns and then you could have that
I think that would be not a problem at
all I haven't done it myself but yeah
very cool okay um so before we dive into
chapter we're going to skip ahead to
chapter 8 um see if there's any
questions just to give a mention of sort
of what we're sort of skipping um there
is an there apis for sort of embedding
uh you know if you want to have a flask
app or Jango app and you want to have a
static Standalone sort of bokeh document
embedded there's a lot of functions for
doing that um there's a section on the
lowle book it up models that really go
sort of goes into more detail there um
anot there's some new annotations that
have been
created things like uh you know if you
want infinite you know span lines or box
annotations there's also new labels that
have come in and again that latc label
is sort of a custom model that was
created you can use label set to easily
label points like this um arrows another
new one just added I think in 021 uh
Luke canaman worked on that so that's a
whole section there for for adding
annotations uh but then what we really
want to talk about today is sort of voke
applications right and so that's we're
going to do so last chapter we'll talk
about today any uh any questions before
we before we dive into the bokeh server
chapter yeah I mean anything you can
access right so I mean if if you're you
know if you know how to get a hold of
that object in the Dom using jQuery or
whatever then absolutely yeah
yeah uh okay good all right any other
questions the question was can the bokeh
a customjs callbacks you know access
other elements on a page and again
whatever you can get a hold of you can
you can manipulate however you want it's
just it's just JavaScript
right uh okay other other
questions excuse me okay uh so let's
just dive in we're going to talk about
the
server uh first note here in bright red
is that um these exercises are actually
outside the Jupiter notebook right so
this is going to require copying and
pasting some code into a file and then
we're going to run a bokeh serve command
on that file and I'll talk about that in
a bit but just so you know uh these are
sort of the codes here in the notebook
but we'll actually have to run them
outside the notebook and I'll show that
in a second okay so what is this bokeh
server supposed to do right so I
mentioned that um you know the way
things work is that we have this python
representation of things these objects
we call models axes grids data sources
you know uh the data you know the the
glyphs that we want to show the tools
the toolbar whatever um and then
basically there's a onetoone mapping
between all of those objects and a set
of JavaScript objects and the way we
connect those is there's this Json
protocol so we turn all the python
serialize it into Json BJs consumes that
and then recreates all of these objects
these real objects and that's what uses
that's what you know does the work to
actually render the plot and do
everything in the browser so that's
really nice and fantastic and again that
that decoupling affords us the
opportunity to have things like R Boke
and um b. scholar Bok dot you know I
keep threatening to write a mat
lab uh binding for bokeh but I haven't
had a chance to do that yet but you know
any language you would care to write a
binding for you could if it can generate
the right Json um and so that's that's
really powerful in of itself but with
the bokeh
server what it purpose is to do is we
want to be able to create these
documents with these models in them on
the python side on the on the browser
side and be able to keep them in sync
automatically so if I make a change to
the python object like I change some
data or I change range uh the plot
updates automatically the the UI updates
automatically and if I have some event
that happens on the browser if I make a
selection or if I Pan the plot or if I
make a a selection from a dropdown or or
some other widget I want to be able to
have python code respond to that so I
really want to have real true python
code executing right so I can't you know
I can't call pandis in my customjs
callbacks because if pandis doesn't
exist in the browser I'd love to have a
JS version of pandis but that doesn't
exist um so uh with the Boke server
though I can have a call back in Python
that runs in the server that actually
does call pandas and does some real work
in Python in response to a selection or
into a widget or whatever and so let's
take a look at sort of how that works so
that but that's the main purpose of the
bookus Ser to keep the to keep uh things
in sync to keep the python side the
JavaScript side completely in sync right
so uh that the bidirectional nature of
this allows us to do some really
powerful things so let's take a quick
look so let's start out with sort of
hello bokeh example here I'm going to
copy well let's take a look at the code
and then I'm going to run it
so typically in bokeh applications you
need to import something called Kuro
this is the current document right so
the current document is the thing that
holds all of these models it's just a
big collection uh I'm going to put all
of my uh things that I'm going to create
in a column and what I'm going to create
is a text input widget a button widget
and a paragraph note I'm not actually
even going to create a plot here it's
not required um so that's actually
something that surprises people
sometimes but um you know we can keep
whatever we want to keep in sync and if
it's just widgets that's perfectly fine
so the button uh we just have a button
that says say hi we have a text input
widget that starts uh by saying you know
Bok we have this empty paragraph widget
that we're going to add uh we're going
to put all of those in this column so we
have the button the input and the output
in a
column and then also typically we're
going to call something called add root
so on the kurur do we call add root and
we add our
layout now what actually puts things
together is right here I have this
function update and it says
it changes the text property of my
output box to be hello plus whatever the
value of the input box is and then I set
that as my call back I say button on
click call this update function okay so
I can take this
code and I can put it in a text file see
if I can get
my thing to leave full screen okay we'll
C here so here if I go to I think the
temp
directory this
at
okay we'll go there here uh if I go to
my temp directory and I also want to
activate my Pi data cond environment um
here I have created hello.py is that
font make that
bigger so this is just that code copied
into a text file right I just copied and
pasted it from The Notebook uh and the
way I run this is I'm going to call the
bouet command and I want to serve this
and I actually want to open up a window
as well so I'll call Bou serve D- show
uh and I want to call
hello.py and when I do that I get this
running application and what happens
well if I say say hi it says hello bokeh
if I say hello Pi
Data San Francisco I get hello P San
Francisco so again just a couple of
lines of python right you know uh I'm
able to have this sort of nice web app
that's driven by whatever in the pie
data stack that I would care to use
right if I if I want to call you know
anything panda or numpy or whatever in
that call pack I can and I can connect
this web app to you know to that
powerful python ecosystem and I can
create as many of these as I need to
right so uh obviously the amount of work
that the app does is going to dictate
how many you know if I want to scale
these kind of apps out it depends on how
much work the app does as to how many
you know Boke servers I would need to
run but every time I hit this URL I get
a new one right uh and so there's this
many connections running and I can say
hello uh Pi data
again and so all those are different
right every session gets its own and so
again this is what happens when you go
to the demo. boots.com site and you look
at the apps that are hosted there
there's actually I think something like
16 bokeh Serv running we just ran a
bunch of them on some ec2 instance
behind an engine X you know load
balancer and uh and so we can have
pretty much as many people hitting that
as we need yeah
question yeah so there are options to
control things like timeout if you want
uh the session to timeout
um or as soon as the uh you know the
connections closed the session gets
terminated after some timeout as well um
there are some additional features that
I want to add that are not there yet but
I'm hoping to add in the near future for
instance things like uh um some busy
messages so if you're doing something
that's sort of long-term and blocking
right now there's not a great facility
for sort of indicating that with a like
a spinner or something that's a pretty
easy addition to our protocol um but
also if we want to have things like
reconnecting sessions that's right now
you would you get a new Fresh session
every time you reload this page uh or
Force reload is another protocol message
I want to add but right now again you
can control the timeout explicitly um
you know if you want to set some Maximum
timeout uh and of course when the
connection is closed when the tab's
closed it'll it'll time out after that
as well so so there's
one so this is actually so yeah so it's
run in tornado um and so there's not an
active kernel this doesn't use like
jupyter kernel there's just a tornado
app and so if you have if you have
things that are blocking there are ways
to use for instance threads to offload
that work uh and well I'll show where
the documentation and some examples of
that are uh so the key is since we're
using tornado which is this asynchronous
framework you might have seen in the
last talk you want to make sure you know
that the uh that the tornado handlers
respond fairly quickly right uh and so a
lot of things that's perfectly fine uh
you know you'd be surprised what
responds really quickly on a on a on a
you know sufficiently beefy box but if
you're doing something that really takes
a long time like calling out to sklearn
you'd probably want to use some of the
threading techniques which I can point
people to to actually have that happen
and then and then update a little bit
later because you don't want to you
don't want to block um you know for too
long okay but uh
yes if yeah if you're only running one
server so that's one reason why I said
there's there's sort of a curve of
amount of work that any given call back
does versus how many bokeh servers you
might want to run and so the nice thing
is that the Boke server very
horizontally scalable if you need more
capacity you can just run more of them
uh and so for instance there's document
on how to run them by an aach behind an
Apache load balancer behind an enginex
load balancer um you know if your
service like this I don't imagine
there's any number of connections like
this this could handle any number of
connections right because it's not
really doing any work right but if you
wanted to call out to like sklearn where
it was doing really real work um uh
you'd if you probably would want to use
some of the threading techniques that I
can sort of show you point you to
documentation uh in a second uh and if
you didn't then it would yeah it would
block a single server so that's you know
that's just the nature of tornado but
what's the
yeah so right now this is just an auto
layout we put them in a column but it is
possible to use a custom template so if
we go back to um you know we go back to
Boke demo. boots.com
we go back here uh this one is using a
custom Ginger template to sort of place
things more sophisticated right you know
um or actually I know the one that
really uses this uh this one right here
uses a custom Ginger template so the
actual yoube embed is in the template uh
and then the bokeh application is just
sort of embedded here in the center and
I think all this text is in the template
as well so you know if if you're in the
realm of like a single page app you can
just run it directly from the bouet
server obviously if you have a more
complicated sort of site you can embed
these bouet applications in a variety of
ways into like a flask app or Django app
or pyramid app or whatever um okay cool
good questions um so let's take a look
at the next example um any questions
about that
first
okay so let's actually take a look at
yeah we're running out of time so well
so here the exercise was to add um
another widget here that adds some more
examples let's see if we can do that
maybe right quick uh let's take a few
minutes and if people want to play
around with that you can otherwise I
will try to add a a select box as well
um let's go up
here so I'll have to remember the syn if
I go
to
widgets going to add a
select no well so the call back is
running when when when the value changes
that calls but the actual implementation
is wrapping some JavaScript widget right
our default widgets I think are just
fairly bog standard like some some
bootstrap widgets but you can actually
wrap any javascrip Library you want um
one of my uh colleagues um uh Sarah bird
just is working on a client project and
wrapped the ion range slider which is a
really really nice sort of more
sophisticated range slider with double
ends and dates and and looks really
great and so she wrote a custom
extension that basically adapts you know
this JavaScript API to whatever the
bouet properties are on this model and
it just works out really nicely you
don't have to write much code to do it
but if you have you know if you want to
wrap like leaflet or I did WRA VJs or if
there's some really cool you know other
JavaScript library that you want to
connect you know to psychic learn or to
pandis you know this is the way you can
do that this is the Boke server s of
that bridge let you connect the pi data
stack to you know arbitrary sort of
whatever JavaScript capability you
want um yeah so between bokeh server the
between the the bokeh application in the
browser and the server there's adjacent
protocol yeah that's
specified yeah basically it's any all of
these models have properties and the
properties have types that are specified
in Python in fact that might be
instructive to look at right quick um if
I actually look at you know what is a
python model look like take a bit of a
diversion here um and I go to BKE and I
go to models and I go to um let's look
at you know ranges and then I want to
look at a range 1D all almost all the
python models are very declarative they
have these traits like things so a range
is a start and an end and an end is
either a float or a date time or an INT
right and there's no actual code here
and so that's our these are
automatically serialized in the right
way for the protocol this also plugs
into our documentation really well it
also validates if you set start equal to
like a string you'll get a nice
validation error that says hey start has
to be a float or an in you know or a
daytime um similar for uh you know a
data range here you can give it a list
of names of renderers right to actually
do the auto auto ranging over by default
it uses any render that it can find but
if you want to restrict it to a certain
set of renders you can give it a list of
the names of them or a list of the
renderers
themselves BJs matches these exactly in
fact we have tests that make sure that
the python models match up exactly to
the JavaScript models in terms of what
their properties are and so the protocol
is actually for updating these
properties between Python and JavaScript
models yeah and so the way you write a
custom extension is that you adapt
whatever the JS API is to some set of
properties on some model that you create
yeah good questions okay I'm glad we got
to talk about that
um let's see we are running a bit low on
time let me let's skip this exercise
here I was going to add a select box
that just had a bunch of different
greetings you know hello uh B vindu and
and you know Aloha whatever but that
would be adding a select box and then
adding that to the call to the call back
to use the different greeting instead of
hello right so but let's go ahead and
move on to the second example here where
we put some plots together so again
let's take a look at the code and then
I'll run this
example so again import some numpy we
import Kuro is very important for our
server applications uh in this case I've
got rows and
columns uh I'm creating a column data
source and a figure um and then I want
to select box and a text input and so I
create my
figure I add some circles to it uh and
I've got also a select box that has a
list of colors in this case it's going
to be things like uh where's my list of
colors somewhere oh yeah black fire
brick Navy Olive Golden Rod right colors
uh and then the text input just has a
number of Point has a number of points
with the title in this case I'm going to
start with 200 um whenever the update
you know the update uh whenever the the
select box is is changed I'm going to
call update color which calls that glyph
and sets its fill color to whatever is
in the in the select
box whenever the text box is changed I'm
going to call update points which
recomputes the value it calls this get
data function for end points and it sets
the data equal to that right so I'm
updating the the DAT attribute of my
column data source uh and just the just
the fact that I do those right causes
the change to be mirrored so when when
this call back is called and source.
data equals some new set of data you
know new data dictionary um that
automatically gets mirrored into the
browser and causes the update in the
browser so finally I put all these
things in my you know my layout I make a
a row with my widgets and I put that on
top of the plot and then I can call
again add root typically one of the very
last things we do is call add root uh
and then we can run it so let's take a
look at
that so this one is now uh I think I
called it
app.py right so great so maybe I want to
change the color to fire brick so I can
do that and my call back changes the
glyph do fill color based on the SL
based on that select box and it changes
all of the uh glyph colors so I can pick
any of these that I want right uh I can
say I want 2,000 points and I get 2,000
points instead of uh you know or I want
20,000 points right starts to look a
little bit weird there uh I didn't add
any tools so we don't see any of that
sort of automatic decimation but um
yes yeah exactly let's take a look
exactly right so uh what happens is I
called input.on change whenever the
value changes I want to call update
points so that change triggered this
call back which triggers this python de
cuute which says I want to get new data
for end points in this case 2,000 or
20,000 uh and then it sets it to source.
dat just setting source. dat equal to a
new value that's automatically detected
and causes the new data to be sent right
so there's no explicit triggering you
have to do um that was an important sort
of design consideration so I should
mention this is actually the sort of the
second generation B server um we had an
original bokeh server it was a very
different um and it was not very
successful completely honest uh there
are probably more people using this Bok
server today than there were in the two
years that the old one existed um uh I
mean literally today uh in this
room um it was sort of flas based it it
couldn't do the perform things we wanted
to do with sort of streaming updates or
incremental patching updates efficiently
um and it would also required like a lot
of explicit triggering of updates you
know it was sort of fragile and error
prone and also had like some classes you
had to Define one of the things we
wanted to really be able to do is just
write a simple script there's no class
here you could certainly use classes if
you wanted to but this is just a simple
script right simple script I'm changing
attributes on objects there's no special
classes I have to make there's no
explicit triggering I have to remember
to do it just automatically syncs things
up and that was a really um important
considerations I should call out
specifically um a lot of the work on the
new server was done by Havoc Pennington
who if you know is one of the original
authors of gtk and gome he tremendous
tremendous um work on the server and
very grateful to have had his help and
assistance working on this but um anyway
yeah so that's that's the m so the the
new server I think has been validated
just by the fact that there are lots of
people using it and doing really
interesting things with it uh and it's
been very uh gratifying to see that that
sort of
uptake
it's the it's the input. value yes
exactly so this says whenever the value
changes whenever the value property of
the input changes call this function and
so then it actually uses input. value
right so yeah so whenever you whenever
it changes on the uh whenever it changes
on the JavaScript side that change is
automatically mirrored in the server now
there may or may not be a call back the
change is mirrored regardless right uh
but I've said specifically if there is a
change here on value I want to call this
function and the function takes input.
value and does something with it exactly
it's bidirectional and that's why this
all hangs together and works out really
nicely and why I think it's is quite
powerful so okay so again you could add
more widgets to this uh I'd actually
like to show off some more examples so
I'm just going to go go to the last data
the last example here uh which is this
streaming data example so I think it's
one thing that's been alluded to over
here is that you know if you have to
replace all the data and you've got
20,000 points that's kind of a lot of
network traffic there are certain cases
where you can optimize that and do
better right what if you're streaming
data and you only need like the the
newest data point every time you don't
need to send all the data if you're just
adding one more point to the end so we
recently added a stream method to column
data sources so that you can specify hey
I want to tack on new values to all the
columns one or two or 10 or however many
um and I don't want to have to resend
all the data and so it's a much more
efficient protocol in this
case um I don't go over the code too
much you can study it I create sort of a
a circle and then I create another
Circle and uh basically I I well let's
just run it
the last thing I want to mention though
is I create something called a periodic
call back here so in addition to uh call
backs based on models changing you can
add things like periodic call back so in
this case I want something to run every
150 milliseconds uh on the server and so
that's what's going to happen so let's
take a look at what it does and then I
think it'll make more sense to talk
about the code so if I call stream.
piy so this is adding a new point and
I've also specified a Max rollover value
so as soon soon as it gets to I think 18
points it just deletes the it just
starts dropping data off the beginning
of the columns right and so that's again
only sending you know one value every
update instead of sending all the values
every update U and so this is just
having the circle sort of rotate around
you know go around the circle so we
could
change um you know we could change uh
the value here if we go to it's VI
stream.
Pi so yeah the roll over is 18 but let's
change the roll over to be like you know
five and now it'll start dropping data
much sooner um you know so there's five
points that sort of travel around it
just starts you know as soon as as soon
as the length of the columns gets to be
five it starts you know adding the new
value and then dropping off the oldest
value yeah it has to be yeah yeah I mean
it's not impossible to do things like uh
compute damage regions um and try to do
partial redraws but that's a lot of
logic and a lot of complication and we
haven't found it to be necessary
especially um uh for a couple of reasons
one is that uh well one the HTML canvas
is actually really performant I was kind
of surprised um I've worked on pre other
libraries previously I worked on a
library called choco with Peter Wang
about 10 years ago which was sort of a
python Rich client Library used Cairo as
a backend I worked on another Cairo
backend project maybe seven or eight
years ago and you know they were
occasionally slow but the canvas
optimizations in browsers these days is
just amazing and it's been great but
addition that we also have that level of
detail down sampling that's possible to
add we also have webgl support so not
every single glyph is possible to use
webgl support but basically all the
markers lines a lot of common glyphs you
can have webgl support So if you really
want to draw 100,000 points on one
canvas you can do that and it updates
and you can pan and zoom very fast um
once you get beyond that you get into
the data Shader territory once you start
to have millions or tens or hundreds of
millions of points that's where you
start looking at data Shader or you
could write an app that does down
sampling I guess it's another option but
um anyway that's so we sort of have a
range of capabilities across different
data sizes but so in addition to the
streaming um I should also mention an
even newer capability which I don't have
a demo to show unfortunately but in
addition to stream so stream is useful
in the use case where you want to add
new values to every column you know just
a few and so you want to have do that an
efficient update it might be the case
that you just want to update a couple of
values in the middle of some columns you
know just here and there like maybe you
have you know some columns that have
10,000 data points and you have five or
six of those columns and you just want
to update three or four things in the
middle there's now a uh data source.
patch that lets you specify just a few
values you know wherever you want in the
middle of a data source and it will send
just those couple of values and so it's
again much more efficient than updating
all the data so you know this is again
trying to trying to really squeeze more
performance out of uh the B server I'm
actually really happy that we're still
in a place where there's a lot of low
hanging fruit even as good as it is um
another thing we haven't done yet but
that I would like to do with the next
few months is um a binary transport
protocol for arrays so right now we just
sort of Jason all the things but I had
demonstrated a prototype where you can
actually send a numpy u array directly
into a typed array buffer in the browser
without any kind of uh encoding and so
uh we actually already have a lot of the
plumbing to support that we we
deliberately wrote the protocol to
support um segmented messages so you
wouldn't have to do any copying of
buffers to have things like that uh we
just haven't been able to you know get
around doing the last mile of that but I
think we're in a good position to have a
lot of really great things
so uh so that would just be sending the
the bites so well we could we could I
mean
well so the the proof of concept that I
did just sent numpy ASB into a Type 3
buffer which is probably the absolute
minimum amount of work you can do now if
you're running on maybe an SGI box or
something that's big Indian I guess we
have to talk about that right you maybe
you want to turn that off but uh because
but yeah it's not even we or we could
maybe use something like message pack um
to construct those those binary buffers
as well but I like I said I did a quick
proof of concept and I just sent as
numpy you know array. asbes directly
into the browser and I got out what I
wanted and it worked great so anyway
that's um that's coming coming
attractions so last few things just
before we adjourn I have a few more
minutes uh is I just wanted to show a
few examples that aren't on dem.
boots.com uh because there are a few
newer ones uh so I mentioned in terms of
streaming one that's kind of nice is
this ohlc
demo uh so I do
Boke serve D show ohlc so this brings up
a nice demo that's basically streaming
sort of indicators for financial data
it's my Candlestick chart it's got the
macd indicator at the bottom um you know
it's got a few sliders here if I want to
make a lot of money I can move the mean
way up and you know that's great or if I
want to have a lot of volatility I can
change the standard deviation um there's
also different kinds of moving averages
maybe I want a 12 tick exponential
moving average or a you know a 26 tick
exponential moving average and we can
change that to just quick guess um the
code the the script that that I just ran
has not only the code for the bou plots
it has and not only the code for
computing the Mac the indicator it's
also got the synthetic uh tick it has
the code to to generate the synthetic
tick data um any guesses on how much
python code it is to have a web app that
does
this
huh I always get low ball it's always
like 10 no so it's it's under 100 lines
of python code that's including the
simulation right I mean so there code to
do the simulation uh as well as all the
code I mean and you just run Boke Sero
on it and you get this nice sort of
updating plot and again this is you know
you can move around and pan and you can
say I want to start following the data
again if you actually wait long enough
you know if you move around back here
you can start to see where the data
starts to fall off the back right so but
you can control that window of how much
you want um to send and again the whole
idea is not to send an infinite amount
of data but anyway so that's that's a
nice example I think um
there's yes those are all under examples
app yeah exactly so I'm in the bokeh
examples app directory may be kind of
hard to see uh let's make this
bigger and you can see there's the ohlc
the selection histogram is there the
spectrogram example that I showed
earlier is here um that cross filter one
here's the clustering one movies oh line
off is is new let's show this one this
there's there's a customjs version of
this as well as a uh other one this is
nice because now it's really easy to
sort of control what's on or off right I
can just click this here we're actually
going to add a function to have
interactive Legend so you could just
click on the legend for instance and
turn things on and off but uh you know
just a nice be able to do that very
easily
um oh for animated this was cool so we
someone saw this as a a thing online we
thought this would be really cool to
reproduce as a bokeh plot so this is
sort of a an example of forier synthesis
and Analysis using bokeh plot right so
it just sort of shows you know here the
here are the different uh the first four
harmonics individually and then that's
top plot is sort of what they look like
when they're added up and so again um
you know fun fun stuff you can do with
booket plots but okay last thing I
wanted to show is the documentation just
to show people where it's at so you know
where to find more information so we've
seen a lot of basic capability if you
really wanted to deploy a site um you
know and you want to have it scale I
mean if you just want to run it locally
that's great if you want to share the
script with someone to run locally
that's great if you have a small group
no problem deploying a simple app it's
great there are more sophisticated use
cases we try to have um as much
documentation as we can uh so you go to
this running bokeh server um one there's
some nice information just about what
use case scenarios are really good um
there's a couple of other ways to use
the BOK server too there is this output
server function and b. client I will
state that I I'm going to be very
opinionated and say that writing the
apps like we've seen today in the
tutorial is probably the absolute
preferred way to use the bokeh server
but there is this client API where you
can basically talk to the server from a
separate python process if you if you
really want to um so anyway have a lot
of information about bokeh applications
the directory structure that you would
need to create you can add static things
there's a a theme. yaml you could add to
cut down the code you have to write you
can add a template you know a Ginga
template as well um and so you can sort
of see a lot of things here what you
know more full-fledged thing might look
like if you have you know model models
that you want to load extensions that
you have um but uh there's also some
information here on threads right so
there are considerations if you want to
do work in Threads basically updating
Boke models has to happen from the main
tornado a loop uh and so if you want to
use threads there's basically one safe
thing you can do from a thread which is
to schedule a call back on the next tick
and so you have to kind of take some
care to coordinate things and you can
see an example here of exactly how to do
that if you want to do blocking work in
a separate thread Um this can show you
how to do it um there 's also something
called unlocked callbacks I don't want
to go into detail but there's
explanation here of what that is there's
also some life cycle hooks if you want
to have code that runs just when the
server's loaded or just when a
particular session is created you can do
that um the spectrogram example does
this actually so the spectrogram example
is doing has a separate thread that's
doing the audio analysis and the forier
and the power Spectrum computation uh
and it it sets that up in one of these
life cycle Hooks and then individual
sessions just read from a readon copy of
the current data to update the plot and
so that's why you don't have every
session Computing that data there's just
one thread Computing that
data uh and there's also uh information
about deployment if you want to do
things behind you know deploying behind
enginex right so there's sort of a
sample enginex config here for doing
that uh a sample Apache config you know
if you want to run behind Apache for
your um thing if you want to set up
reverse proxying with engine X and SSL
uh there's an example here as well uh
for a config uh as well as load
balancing and then finally a brief
discussion of things like supervisor D
so there's actually a the repo that
deploys that demo bokei plot site is on
GitHub so you can examine the sort of
the full deployment there that's sort of
a fairly sophisticated deployment and
you can look at it um but there you go
anyway there's also a num procs you know
if you want to scale out to more than uh
more easily uh okay so I think that's
about it just wanted to point everyone
to where those docs are oh the mailing
list is a really good use okay last
thing the mailing list is a really great
um resource for folks uh because
sometimes when we're too slow at
figuring things out we have amazing
users and they figure things out too
there's been recent questions about I
don't I want to run a bokeh server app
but I don't want to run a separate bokeh
server process I want to like run it
inside my flas app somehow and I was
like well probably a way to do this I
don't know I've never tried it I don't
haven't had time to try it um but you
should be able to theoretically just
plug in whatever I Loop you want and
someone did it and they figured it out
exactly and so they actually have a
single flask app here that creates a
tornado I Loop and let's see if I have
it running and then yeah that doesn't
run a bokeh server separately they call
bokeh serve. serve with this homemade I
Loop that they created inside flask and
they create this and let's go to Local
Host
5667 I think
5677 nope
5667 nope okay what is it 5567 okay
there we
go and so there's two tabs here and
there's Boke server code running right
or here he's actually cycling through
and updating you know just in in a very
tight Loop updating the values of all
these very quickly and so there's just
one flas G running and there's not a
separate B server he started a tornado I
Loop directly in in flask and then pass
that I loop on to Boke serf
programmatically so this is sort of uh
Cutting Edge stuff that it took someone
else to you know figure out how to do
but we have like I said terrific users a
terrific Community um we're up to about
600 I think users on our mailing list um
and again n0 contributors which is
amazing and uh so please come join us
help us yeah was was the server was up
the data you're not not looking ater
right something like that I actually
have this is so new I actually have not
had a chance to examine this code in
detail I had to make a few changes to
get it to run on OSX instead of windows
but beyond that uh I haven't had a
chance to look at it in closely I just
sort of L ran it and said wow that's
amazing uh but anyway yeah so the
mailing list is a great resource um we
monitor stock overflow as best we can as
well but certainly encourage people to
come to the mailing list so okay uh
we're just about out of time any last
questions before we adjourn yeah do talk
about 1.0 oh yeah 1.0 so um we're trying
to our best to do that in the next um I
would say a couple of months right now
the team is pretty spread thin we have
some client work that people want us to
do using bokeh and that's an important
method of supporting the project so we
we have to give that some attention um
you know part of 1.0 is getting in a few
things that are just long-standing
requests people want color color bars uh
hopefully the Headless you know
programmatic saving of svgs and pgs um
the layout work that just went in um
things like that some of the missing
annotations that we didn't have like you
just Arrow simple things that we just
never got around to but the main work of
1.0 is really about locking down apis uh
we have a lot of um you know we have a
lot of Machinery in our build and
continuous integration testing already
but um I really want to be able to
report out I want to be able to
confidently Implement semantic
versioning and know exactly that you
know if something changes it wasn't un
intentional and I want to be able to
report that out very well and so we have
someone currently working on developing
some tools to help automate that process
and Report out you know uh so that we
can completely be completely confident
in our semantic versioning starting at
1.0 and going forward so that um you
know that there's no unintentional API
changes we've been uh progressively I
think more strict about that over time
obviously when the project was new we
changed whatever we need to change we
didn't have any users uh but now we have
users and so they get annoyed when
things change and so we're trying to get
much much better about that and I think
we've gotten much better about that but
still I want to be able to have no
doubts about API changes and so
implementing that is one of the biggest
tasks for 1.0 and then I think you know
there's certainly lots more to do that
we could do but I think we're in a place
where it's stable enough that we can
build upon without having to change
things so that's that's what so my best
guess is a couple of months I definitely
you know uh it sort of depends on the
bandwidth of the the team and and maybe
new contributors coming on but um that's
sort of I think where we're at so 1.0 is
a few months
away other
questions okay well thanks oh question
last in the bill
oh great question okay last question um
let me actually just show you so this
was written by Ryan hen who is one of
the collaborators on the DARPA X data
initiative that sort of initially helped
fund uh bokeh um it's completely
different from Boke right so there's no
reason that the API has to be anything
like the python API it can be very sort
of R specific and that's exactly what it
is um the limitations are entirely
dependent on what Ryan has implemented
you know um but he does a good job so
here's some examples of what he has
currently you know you can see here's my
nice uh he calls ly points with this and
and you know color equal species and so
he's added stuff kind of like the highle
charts thing to automatically do you
know figuring out what should go in
there and generating a Legend um here's
one that puts in this regression line uh
you know here's a chart that um you know
has a histogram so he implemented a
histogram that generates a bokeh plot of
that
histogram um here's this periodic table
you know he sort of customized the tool
tip to his liking um some go type stuff
excuse me uh map you know maps with
bokeh plots over overlaid um so again
it's it's a very you know our specific
API has nothing to do with the python
API what it does is it generates again
the correct Json that's all that matters
is that you know you have whatever AP
API you want as long as it generates
that correct Json um I don't have a page
to link to the Boke out Scala and I
actually don't really know Scala so
wouldn't really be able to comment much
on it but I imagine the Scala API
doesn't look very much like the python
API either um
but anyway so these are just a bunch of
examples of B so this is on hen.
github.io um if you just you know Google
search for for R Boke it should show up
as one of the first results
um
uh you know conceptually it's possible
that you know maybe someday we could
actually have R code Drive Boke server
in some way uh right now that's sort of
beyond the current capabilities but um
it would be interesting to see I think
he's actually added quite a bit of stuff
here these are all look new to me so
this is pretty cool
Ryan tries to keep up on our releases
pretty well I think he's been
integrating the latest 02 and 021 stuff
and should have a new release quite soon
of that so anyway that's there if you if
you're using R It's seems pretty cool as
well
so um not yet we'd like to add some
stuff to bokeh charts that can do like
sort of that auto fating um and you can
certainly write a bokeh app that does
that we have to write python code to
sort of do it there's not like a facet
rout yet but we'd like to add something
like that um if we did the G plot it
would share everything share the same
data yeah yeah absolutely yeah there
there is an example there is actually
there is a python example that's
basically identical to this one uh it's
just you have to sort of set up that
grid yourself and and the ranges
yourself no yeah yeah great okay I think
like I said last question because we're
running out of time thank you everyone
for coming I hope this been useful
informative hope you had a great first
day here at Pi data and hope to see
anyone and everyone in the next few days
here uh please don't hesitate to stop by
the Continuum table at the back of this
room I should be there all weekend and
looking forward to chatting with anyone
who wants to talk b or anything else
thanks